hello everyone welcome to this live
session on data analysis with Excel by
simply learn
in today's session we will learn about
Microsoft Excel and how it can be used
to perform data analysis
our instructors with good industry
experience will help you learn
everything from scratch
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so we will start by understanding the
basics of Microsoft Excel followed by
learning the top Excel functions and
formulas
we will then see how to validate and
format data in Excel moving further we
will learn two important features of
excel that help in analysis of data so
we look at pivot tables and power query
we'll get an idea about using the data
analysis tool pack for performing
statistical analysis such as descriptive
statistics regression analysis and
sampling finally we will focus on
automating tasks in Excel using macros
and VBA so let's get started
hi everyone let's continue learning
Excel so we will learn about functions
and formulas we will learn about
conditional formatting data validation
pivot chart and pivot table
now let's look at a scenario here so one
day in a startup
One Professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another click response well
we can make use of Microsoft Excel to do
this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to their business needs
now
the colleague response well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question says let's go ahead with
Excel and let's train our employees in
Excel
and the suggestion is welcomed which
would make the job easier for them
and they would basically decide on using
Excel so they decide on taking a
training right away and basically
starting to learn Excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use Excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so Excel proves to a be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days various
features in Excel like searching sorting
filtering makes it easier for you to
play with the data and Excel also allows
you to beautify your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and Analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
Excel also provides good security for
your data Excel files have the feature
of password protection this way your
information can be safe
now when we talk about what is Excel and
how it can be used
so Excel or you might have heard a
spreadsheet can be basically used for a
lot of different tasks than just storing
the information in so-called tabular
format
now Microsoft Excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in Excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a small tour to understand how to
work with Excel now to do that what we
can do is we can type in in our search
say for example Excel and just select
your Excel app which is installed and
here you see you have lot of options
which says take a tour drop down list
get started with formulas make your
pivot table going forward with pie
charts and much more so we can click on
this one which says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to Excel and if you
have always wanted to be better at Excel
you have this which can help you so
let's click on Create and that takes us
to the store window now that says
instructions for screen readers which
basically talks about 10 different steps
in which we can learn Excel and using
the spreadsheet app so there are more
than 11 sheets which we see here at the
bottom end and each one gives us a
simple example which we can work on so
for example if I click on ADD now that
takes me to this page which says how do
we add numbers now you might be provided
data which we can upload by loading a
file from our machine or getting data
from a web Source or even connecting to
a database so there are various options
which we will see in some time so here
we have an option which is called Data
you can click on this one and this
basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from SQL
Server from analysis services from odata
data feed you can get in from XML from
data connection Wizard or also from
Microsoft query you can be running in
different queries here which shows up in
the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use and
that basically will display all the
connections for this particular workbook
which we do not have as of now but we
can create them but let's look at simple
examples now you can follow these
instructions here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is from
which row to which row you would want to
add add the data so for example I could
just do a sum here and that shows up all
the different functions which are
available then we can open up a
parenthesis and we can say I would be
interested in totaling the amount
from
column D and I would select for example
D4 so I could be doing this and then I
could say D4
onwards till d 7 so that's the data
which I'm interested in you can close
your parenthesis and hit enter and that
gives you the total
there is also a shortcut for this which
you can always do is we can first delete
this and you can just place your cursor
here and just use your alt and equals
that automatically selects the
numericals which we can anytime expand
or basically collapse so I will
basically select this which says this
function needs two numbers which is
number one and number two and then you
can hit on enter and that gives you the
total so similarly we can be getting in
the data here by selecting all the
fields so here it also says that you can
use a shortcut now what we can also do
is we can add numbers over 50 by
selecting the yellow cell here and then
giving a condition
such as so I can basically use something
like sum if and then open a parenthesis
I can select I would be interested in
this row and then I can even drag and
drop
till here so that tells me the 11 to the
15 you can then put in a comma here and
you can give your condition say for
example we would say I would be
interested in numbers only above 50 and
we can select this
close your codes and then just close
your parenthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total as hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here I could select this now
there is also an option I can click on
home and I can go for something like
Auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says sum is alt plus
equals so it automatically adds up your
values and I can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then I can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be 160. so what we can do is we can
basically select all the numbers which
are lesser than 100 so the way we did
earlier here that can be always a
shortcut so you can always for example
if you would want to avoid typing in the
formula you can always copy it from here
and then just hit on enter so you are
back into this cell and then I can
basically go here and paste the number
and then as per the requirement we are
required to select anything which is
lesser than 100 so what I could do is I
could select here I could say let's say
G and then I can change this value to
g15 and that's one more way now we see
our selected rows have been changed so I
can hit on enter and I can check what is
the result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so I will have to also change
this one to a lesser sign and that
basically gives me the total which is
160. so that's how you can simply add
numbers you can use autosum you can type
in the formula you can select the fields
or you can just place your cursor where
you would be looking for a sum and then
you can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at some easy options of
filling your cells or automatically
populating the values in your cells
within your Excel sheet now here we have
an option which says 100 now we can
click on this and that basically says it
is making a sum of column C4 to D4 so if
I click on this one I can check that
this is row number four which shows up
here and I also know this is column C I
also have D so this equals is basically
giving me a sum of C4 to D4 now what we
can do is we can always place our cursor
here at the right corner and then we can
just drag and drop and this basically
gives me a total of all the numbers for
all different rows so this is one
shortcut which we can do to get the
total Excel will automatically give the
totals which we call as filling down
now what we can do is in the same way if
we would want to get the totals here we
can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me this C11 to c14 total so
it is totaling the rows from C11 so
column C and 11th row till 14th row and
that's the sum now what I can also do is
I can similarly like above we can do a
filling right which basically means
bringing your cursor here and then just
dragging and dropping it all the way
where you would need the totals and this
basically gives me the total there is
one more quick way to check if this is
right so the easiest option would be to
select this cell now what I can also do
is I can just select all of these fields
by just highlighting and selecting all
the fields once it is selected press on
Ctrl R and that gives you the total now
if we would be doing this stop down then
I could select all these rows for this
particular column and then I could do a
control D so that's your filling down
and this one was failing right so this
is an easier option of doing a fill when
you would want to have the formula
applied to every row as it occurs in the
first row or the last row we could test
this by for example selecting these
fields I could delete them and I have
here which says 130 I could just place
my cursor here and I could drag it all
the way up and that should also do the
same magic which we were seeing from top
down so this is a simple way wherein you
can fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate or move your computation to
all the cells
let's look at the split option which
basically helps us in splitting the data
when we have some kind of pattern or
when we have some kind of delimiters in
our data in say one particular column
and we would want to derive the values
out of it so we can always use the
splitting option now the easiest option
would be so for example we have our
email column which has the email IDs and
which we can clearly see has a first
name dot last name now I see that there
is a last name Smith filled up here
first name is empty so what I can also
do is I can just type in say Nancy here
now that's the first name I can again
start typing in the second name and as
soon as you do that you would see a
faded list of numbers and that's your
clue to hit enter and once you do that
you would see all the first names have
been filled in here if you would want to
maintain the case sensitiveness you can
just go ahead and delete these and let's
type in as it occurs so let's say Nancy
as the first name go down to the next
cell and just type in Andy and there is
your grade list so just hit on enter and
that basically fills up your first name
what we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now I can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking Ctrl Z and that's basically
gone what I can also do is I can select
a particular field and then I can go
into home option and under home you have
an option here which says fill so you
can select this and then you can do a
Flash Fill which is what we are doing
here so click on Flash Fill and that
automatically fills up the values so in
this way you can work within your
spreadsheet and you can be filling up
the values where a delimiter by default
is understood and we can split the data
now however sometimes you might have
some data which has a different kind of
delimiter and there is again a smarter
way of splitting your data so you can
always scroll down here and that says
splitting a column based on delimiters
so we have some values in the data
column and these values in each row are
separated by comma so
select this your data is already
selected text to columns delimited comma
selected and now click on next so it
basically says what is the destination
let's select this one
and I can choose what would you want to
have so that shows me this would be my
data preview now I can basically select
this one I can say finish and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in in the columns appropriately
so this is how you can split your data
based on a delimiter and then organize
your data in a better way now there are
some Advanced options which we can learn
later but this basically tells about
using a formula so this is something if
say if we have some name in one cell and
if you would want to split it into first
name your helper column your middle name
last name so that can also be done using
formulas and this basically tells how
would you extract characters from your
left cell and how would you place them
in your right cell so you can try this
activity which is a little more of
advanced option the benefit is that you
can always use this
wherein if you do some kind of
transformation using your formulas if
your original data gets updated then the
split data will also get updated and
that's the benefit of using formulas
where you can place values from one cell
into multiple cells based on execution
of your details in the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your X and Y axis or as I would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become your rows
so what we can do is the simplest way is
you can select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and I would say two rows now I
can select all of these and then I can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt V that's a
shortcut what you can also do is once
you have selected all your Fields you
can just copy them so just do a Ctrl C
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special and once
you do that you need to select the
transpose option over here and click on
OK and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as a mount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed in this particular
format now there is another way of doing
that and again that's using your
formulas so what you can do is you can
transpose with a formula also and that
basically works when you have similar
kind of data so this has six columns and
basically two rows so you can basically
do this so you can select this and
earlier we were doing a copy but now
what we would want to do is we would
want to just look at the row numbers
which tells me it is c33 c34 and it
starts with c and ends in with your H
column so what we can do is we know that
we have six columns and two rows so
transposing that would actually give me
two columns and six rows so what we can
do is we can select two columns and six
rows in our Excel sheet I can then
basically start typing in the message or
I can just go to the address bar and
here I can say
transpose
let's go for c33
h34 it basically selects my data and now
I can just do a control shift and enter
and now if you see all the values have
been populated now you can just place
your cursor in one of the cells but if
you see the address bar the formula
Remains the Same this is because this is
an array formula so we can read more
about an array formula here it's
basically something which performs
calculations and on more than one cell
in an array and in the example here the
array is the original data that is c33
to h34 so your transpose is just
changing the horizontal orientation to
the vertical orientation so this is a
very simple way in which you can
basically use the excels capability to
transpose your data and convert your
rows into columns and columns into rows
apart from working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data sorting the data or basically
splitting your data transposing your
data one of the other requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data and you would want to sort it
in a particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how Excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so let's check that
so if we're going to sort and filter and
say this is the data I have say for
example I would want to sort the values
in the department column alphabetically
so what I can do is I can select
Department column and I'm already in the
Home tab I can straight away go here
which says sort and filter here I can
then say sort A to Z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column and once once I do
this you would see the data has been
sorted but it's not just this data we
can just do a control Z and check what
are the values we have so here we have
meet which is beef and ninety thousand
hundred ten thousand the values then you
have Bakery which should ideally be the
first row if we sort it in an
alphabetical order which goes with
Bakery as desserts you have the values
so we can check this again so select
department and then just do a sort and
filter and let's say sort A to Z and if
you see the data has changed but it's
not just in changing your First Column
but then it has taken care of all the
data however the data has been sorted
based on the department column so you
have Bakery which aligns with deserts
which has the values and now we have all
the data which has been filtered now
what we can also do is we can sort
December's amounts from largest to
smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the December
column let's say 20
000 and then what I can do is I can go
into sort filter and then I can say sort
largest to smallest so if you see Bakery
breads is the row which has the smallest
data or maybe you have Delhi sandwiches
so that one looks also smaller so let's
do a larger to smallest and if I do this
you would see the values have been
shifted now so it is no more based on
the department column because now the
data is being sorted based on the values
in the December column and you see
Bakery which was alphabetically the
first one has become second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes based on
the values these are all string values
or words so it sorts alphabetically if
you have numbers might be you can give
some values and you can sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select if you would
want to select the data so I could do a
custom sort and then I could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the Sorting
needs to be done is it cell values is it
cell color font color conditional
formatting and then you can also choose
the order so that's one more way to do
that now if you scroll down that also
shows how you can sort by date or a
color so for example if you would want
to sort based on the expense date so
there are different options so what I
can do is I can select this date field I
can just do a right click I can go into
sort and then I can choose I would want
to sort oldest to newest so since I
selected the date field it basically has
sorted all the data data and it has
taken the expense date into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so I could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates I would be interested in looking
at I also have sort by color here I can
do a sort oldest or newest or newest to
oldest so I could also use these filters
which have been applied here now we have
the data which is in color so if I would
want to basically select the color
columns or color cells I could select
this I can basically do a right click
here and when I go into sort I could
choose put selected color or cell color
on the top and that basically will make
sure that my data is sorted and it has
also sorted that in a descending order
so in this way you can sort or basically
filter your data what we can also do is
we can add filters so sometimes we can
go for formulas which we would want to
use what we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here now how does the
filter come in there so if I would
select a particular row I could select a
particular row and then I could decide
if I would want to just add a filter to
this one and that's how the filter has
come in so we have the filter what we
can do is we can basically click on this
drop down and then you have something
like number filters so we can always go
here we can basically choose one of
these so we can basically choose above
average so I could select this and then
basically it shows me the values we
could also delete the filter by clicking
on this one and we could say well I'm
not interested in this filter anymore
so I could clear the filter and that
shows me all the values or I could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food I can go in here I can go
into number filters and then I could say
well I'm interested in values which are
below average above average might be
greater than and then I can choose what
is the value so for example if we say I
am interested in food which is greater
than 25 dollars I could give a value
here I could say okay and now I have
applied the filter similarly you can
select this and then you can just clear
your filter and your data is back so
remember no data is lost
it is just hidden or basically based on
the filter not shown so that's good
enough for us and in this way you can
sort and filter the data so for more
details obviously in all the sheets you
have the links which point to more
information on the web and you can
always refer to these so this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data which has been stored
within your Excel within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering it will also be good to learn
how to work with tables or basically
converting your data into a tabular
format and then doing some easy
computations so click on this tables
option here now here we see there is
some data which is in five columns and N
number of rows so I can basically select
this data and then what I can do is I
can insert choose the table option and
then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that I'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learned earlier
how to use and this is basically my
table which is a collection of cells
which has some special features so we
can easily add rows to this table we can
add columns to this table and we can
even do some calculations so for example
here I can click on this one I can
basically enter some field and then I
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example I
would say chocolates
I could give some value here so it's 25
000 might be 35
000 and then basically I can given some
values here now what you can also do is
you can continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this option
here in the top bottom right corner you
can just drag it towards the right and
that basically has automatically created
columns for my next months wherein I can
feed in the data so this is a simpler
way wherein you can keep adding more
rows and columns to your data if that
has been converted in a tabular format
now let me just do a control Z that
basically deletes the columns again Ctrl
Z deletes the last row which we added
and I can stop here or I can even remove
my values by doing multiple control Z
and removing my rows so this is how I
converted my data into a table and then
I can easily work on this what I can
also do is I can do some calculations so
what we can do we have a table here we
have a total field and what we can do is
we can just select one cell here now as
we have learned earlier we can do a alt
and then equals and that basically says
what is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum of the last three
months and if that's what you would want
to do just hit on enter and it has
automatically calculated the totals for
all your rows for these three columns so
the sum formula is getting filled up now
I can select any particular cell and I
can look in my address bar so it has
already given me the formula where it
has started calculating the sum from the
October column till the December column
and has given me the calculated values
of the columns what we can also do is we
can get total rows in the table now
that's a simpler option so what we can
do is we can select any l in this
particular table
and then we see that there is a table
tools design option showing up here now
I can select this and then it says well
let's get a total row so let's select
this and it automatically populates the
total here and if you would want the
average then we could select this and
from the drop down I can select what I'm
interested in so for example I would
want the average values and not the
total I could just select this and that
gives me the average of these values so
we can always do simpler computations
here by converting our data into table
format let's learn about one more
efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here now say for example
you have this data which has the values
in the food column and department is
empty and say for example you would want
to enter the values in Department
however you would want to select the
department should either have produce or
meet and bakery and these are the only
three options which should be available
for any user to fill in the values how
do we do that so we can basically create
a table by pressing Ctrl D so what I can
do is under my department
here I can select one of the cells and
then I can do a control T that basically
converts this into a table I can say
okay and my table is created now what I
can do is once this part is done
we can select all the blank Fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable now under your data tab you
can go in and select data validation and
this has an option called Data
validation click on this which basically
says allow any value so here I will
select I would want to give a list of
values and then I can type in my values
here which I can say produce say for
example meet and then say Bakery now
these are the values so we can click on
OK
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to Apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so I can go into every cell and
then I can basically choose what is the
department which handles this and then
basically I can select one of these from
the drop down so this is an easier
option of creating your drop down and
then feeding in the values from the set
of values which you have defined here on
the right so this is a simple example of
using your drop downs working with your
tables working with your sort and filter
transpose split filling up your data
adding in some data here and similarly
you can use Excel for more than one use
case using its inbuilt features to
easily work with your data let's see how
we can import data or bring in data into
our Excel from your local machine or
from an external web source so what we
can do is we can open up a blank Excel
sheet and say for example you have been
provided a text file or a CSV file and
you would want to import that data into
your Excel sheet that can be easily done
so right now I've opened an Excel sheet
now I can click on data and here I have
an option which says existing
connections from other data sources so
or you can click on connections if you
have already created some so we can
click on from other sources so this is
one option where you can connect to your
different data sources and you can get
the data from one of these what we can
also do is I can click on connections
now it says there is none I can click on
ADD it says well show the connections
where connection files or Network
connection files on this computer so I
can say let's get some files from this
computer now if that does not show up
something so say browse for more and
that basically shows you different
options so let's basically select a
folder where I have some data sets I'll
click in here and this is basically a
folder where I have some data sets now
let me select this particular file and I
know it is a CSV file so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a DOT CSV file which is what we
are interested in so I'll take this file
I'll say open now this basically shows
me the text import wizard option which
says is the file delimited I'll say yes
click on next so I will select comma as
my delimiter I can say text qualifier is
none
now this is my data so my data preview
is already showing me the data is what
is the data in the CSV file you can
click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is General
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so I'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here so we basically have this and now I
can click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data which we have here the
connection which we have created say
open and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on OK and now this
data is automatically inserted in my
Excel file I can basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what I
can do is I can go into my GitHub and
let's say I would be interested in this
CSV file so I can select this and this
is my GitHub path a path on web so I can
click on draw and that basically gives
me the raw path where this particular
file is now you can select this copy
this particular path and here you can
come back to your Excel sheet we would
be interested in getting the data from
web might be from a text file where we
will have to specify the delimiters or
let's go to web and here I can given the
web path from where I would be
interested in getting the file let's
give the GitHub path which is publicly
available and then click on import now
once you click on import it tells me
that two Fields data and value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on OK and now you have the data
coming in but then this basically shows
me in one particular field so what we
can also do is we can just do a control
a that selects all my columns here and
that's my data so we can then basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next we
can select comma and let the text
qualifier be codes it shows me data
preview click on next so you have the
general format it shows the destination
that's the column click on finish and
now your data has been split and you
have the data which you have imported
from web so this is the data which is
coming in from web this is the data
which came in from my local machine and
similarly we can even create connection
with an existing database so I can
basically click on connections if I
would want to do that so I have an
option called connection here and it
says where the selected connections are
used I can basically click on ADD I can
basically choose if I would want to get
the files from Network or from computer
like we did earlier I can click on
browse for more which should show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new SQL Server Connection you can
connect to a new data source coming in
from different place you could basically
choose what kind of connection you would
you want so these are all the different
options which we can go for and we can
basically connect to a database for
example if I have some database and say
for example access database
I can see if there are some files with
that particular database and I can
import it so similarly we can also uh
click in here which says new query and
that also gives you an option of getting
the data from your files from all these
folders from databases so you can
basically click here and then you can
import data from a mySQL database
provided that is set up on your local
machine or on a particular server you
can go from cloud you can get it from
online services you can get it from
other sources which says from web from
your Hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor you can get the
data from different sources and then you
can bring it into your Excel so in this
way you can get your data from different
sources into your Excel into your
spreadsheet and then you can continue
working on those data sets
we have already learned some basic
operations which you can do in Excel and
let's Implement our knowledge by working
on this particular data which is coming
in from housing data set now here if we
see some fields we have agent date
listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been sorted
in newest to oldest order of date listed
so how do we
arrive at this so what I can do is I can
just click on data listed and then I can
either go in here I can select sort I
can get into custom sort and then I can
choose the column based on which I would
want to sort the data so I would look
for the newest data to the oldest data
that means that would mean a descending
order of dates or you could say the
oldest state or the earliest month will
be towards the lower side of your sheet
so here we can select date listed now I
can say let it sort based on Cell values
and the order what we have here so we
have newest to oldest so let's select
this I can say OK and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see an earlier month hour and
earlier month than that in the state
listed so we have sorted our data into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your date column so the result shows
up here now what we can also do is we
can have different questions which we
would want to answer so for example I
would want to sort the data in ascending
order of area and descending order of
agent name how do we do that so let's
look into this so this is here I already
have the result here and how did I get
this so I'm looking for ascending order
of area and descending order of agent
name so we can start with any particular
column that does not matter so for
example if I look into this Excel sheet
I have my agent name select this which
we want in a descending order so we
could either do a sort and then go for
descending sort Z to A we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or I could just say
sort Z to A and then it has arranged the
data based on the agent column being in
descending order now I can go into area
and then I can again do a sort and I
wanted my area column to be used for
sorting the data and ascending to
descending and that basically not only
changes the order of this particular
column but for my complete data so let's
do that and now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so we can see
how many values we have here and the
area values which we see and this is how
you get your result so I'll just do a
control Z and again and I'm back to my
original data and this is the sorted
result which we are seeing at similarly
we can answer other questions for
example sort the data according to the
following order of area that is we are
saying counties
Central and then your county so we can
basically choose in which particular way
we would want to do it so it is County
Central and then again County so if I
look into my G3 so here I basically have
my data which is having some South
County then you have your Central and
then you have your North County so we
would want to sort the data to solar
problem which is according to the
following order so first we go for area
then we go for South County Central and
North County so what we can do is we can
basically have area field selected and I
would want to sort this particular data
so I have South County Central and North
County so I can basically go for custom
sort
and then I can choose which is the value
or column which I'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like cell
values well you can also try to explore
conditional formatting icon if this is
what you would want to use or we can
basically go for just cell values and
here we can say if I would be interested
in first getting my values for South
County so for example I can say custom
list and then I can basically given the
new list here so I can say s
Dot County
and then I would want Central and then I
would want North County
so let's select this
as it exists we can basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with Kelly you have in the 12th
row something like Lang and that's what
we are doing so we can basically arrange
the data in a particular order by
choosing a custom list and then sorting
your data so that's one more simpler
task where we what we have done where we
have sorted the data in the order where
under our area column we first wanted
South County then we wanted Central data
and then we wanted North County so this
is how you can do it now let's look into
one more problem so it says find all the
houses in the central area and we would
want to basically apply a regular filter
let's let's see how do we do that so we
can click on this and here we have the
data so the problem statement is we
would want to find all the houses in
Central Area now how do we do that we
can do a sorting but we would want to
use the filter which you see here is
implemented so how do you do it so you
can select this area and say for example
I would want to apply filter I can just
go in here and I can say let's get a
filter on my first row and now I have
filters applied so we are interested in
looking into the Central Area houses
let's go in here it says all these
fields are selected that means it shows
everything wherein your area has all
these values let's unselect this and
then I will only be interested in the
central so let's say okay and then say
okay so now you see that the area filter
has been applied and we are looking at
the central column so what we have done
is we have applied a simple filter and
we are looking at our data at any point
of time if you do not want the filter
then what I can do is I can select this
and I can say well I'm interested in all
the data so I could do this or you can
clear the filters from area and you get
your data back so that's in one way you
can filter out your data so let's look
at an example of sort and filter where
we might have to filter the data based
on two columns or multiple columns with
different kind of values where it could
be and and or condition now say for
example this is the data I have and this
is the question which we need to answer
such as find the list of all houses in
the central region with pool and South
County without pool now if it was a
simple filter based on one cell I could
have just selected my header row I could
have then applied the filter
and once I have the filter I can look in
area where I have three regions so I'm
only interested in Central and South
County so I can get rid of North County
and that's fine but then we have two
different conditions here so we need the
data in central region to have the value
for pool being true
and for South County the value has to be
without pool now how do we do that so
what we can do is we can first create a
copy of these headers here so let me do
that now the area has to be South County
so basically I can either just select
this and I can choose this value
and then I can select this and then I
can choose Central so that's the
criteria which I have and the pool value
has to be so central region should be
with pool so then this one
basically has to be true
and this one has to be basically false
so south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now to get my result we
can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is M column and
eighth row okay so we would want the
result here so let's go ahead and now
click on data and then in filter you
have an option called Advanced and here
what I can do is I can say I would want
to filter the list in the place but
that's not what I would want to do so
I'll say copy to another location and
here if you see the list range will tell
me that this is the data so A1 to J 126
so a to J column selected and all the
rows
criteria range is basically based on
what I have given here so that is m
from 1
to V which is 3
so I'm selecting these columns and then
I am saying all the way whatever
criteria I have given and copy 2 I am
saying M8
to V8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay and now I have my data
which has been filtered and I have my
area which is South County that is
without Pool Central with pool again
South County without pool and then if
you look at your central value that's
pool so this is an advanced filter which
we have applied where simply we have
filtered the data based on two columns
and then we have our result so in this
way you can have your customized filter
applied on two different columns and get
your data which can be either replacing
the existing content or in the same
sheet in different set of columns and
rows you can have your result let's look
at one more example of filtering where
you are trying to filter the data based
on a and condition condition being met
in two different columns and then you
would want to filter out the data for
only specific columns so the situation
is the agents with a house in North
County that should be County area having
two and a single type family so we are
talking about two bedrooms and we would
basically have a single type family and
here the criteria is that if we would
want to only populate these columns
which is Agent area bedroom and type now
what you can do is as I explained
earlier that you can get your result in
the same sheet in a different location
so here I have created these headers
which says agent area bedrooms and type
now this is basically a copy of all the
columns what we have here agent data
listed area list Place bedrooms bath
square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
Advanced criteria to filter the data so
the conditions which need to be met is
we need to look at North County so for
example here in area I can basically go
ahead and select one of the values North
County now the criteria is having two
bedrooms only so let's say bedrooms and
let's say the value should be 2
and then basically I am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type I
can give the criteria single type so
this is my and condition so we are
saying North County area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if I select this this one tells me
that this is m one row onwards till V
2 so this is what we have and we would
want to filter based on this so let's go
ahead and then go for data filter
Advanced and here in advanced it says
filter the list in place now that's not
what we would want to do so I'll say
copy to another location this basically
selects the list range so which is
telling me A1
2 J 126 so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on M1 V2 which we have given
here and copy to I would say for example
from M7
two
P seven now this is the area where I
would this is the place where I want the
result let's say okay and now I get my
data which is based on the question
which has been
foreign
welcome to this live session on data
analysis with Excel by simply learn
in today's session we will learn about
Microsoft Excel and how it can be used
to perform data analysis
our instructors with good industry
experience will help you learn
everything from scratch
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so we will start by understanding the
basics of Microsoft Excel followed by
learning the top Excel functions and
formulas
we will then see how to validate and
format data in Excel moving further we
will learn two important features of
excel that help in analysis of data so
we look at pivot tables and power query
we'll get an idea about using the data
analysis tool pack for performing
statistical analysis such as descriptive
statistics regression analysis and
sampling
finally we will focus on automating
tasks in Excel using macros and VBA so
let's get started
hi everyone let's continue learning
Excel so
we will learn about functions and
formulas we will learn about conditional
formatting data validation pivot chart
and pivot table
now let's look at a scenario here so one
day in a startup
One Professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another click response well
we can make use of Microsoft Excel to do
this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to their business needs
now
the colleague response well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question says let's go ahead with
Excel and let's train our employees in
Excel
and
the suggestion is welcomed which would
make the job easier for them
and they would basically decide on using
Excel so they decide on taking a
training right away and basically
starting to learn Excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use Excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so Excel proves to a be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days various
features in Excel like searching sorting
filtering makes it easier for you to
play with the data and Excel also allows
you to beautify your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and Analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
Excel also provides good security for
your data Excel files have the feature
of password protection this way your
information can be safe
now when we talk about what is Excel and
how it can be used so Excel or you might
have heard a spreadsheet can be
basically used for a lot of different
tasks than just storing the information
in so-called tabular format
now Microsoft Excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in Excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a small tour to understand how to
work with Excel now to do that what we
can do is we can type in in our search
say for example Excel and just select
your Excel app which is installed and
here you see you have lot of options
which says take a tour drop down list
get started with formulas make your
pivot table going forward with pie
charts and much more so we can click on
this one which says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to Excel and if you
have always wanted to be better at Excel
you have this which can help you so
let's click on Create and that takes us
to the store window now that says
instructions for screen readers which
basically talks about 10 different steps
in which we can learn Excel and using
the spreadsheet app so there are more
than 11 sheets which we see here at the
bottom end and each one gives us a
simple example which we can work on so
for example if I click on ADD now that
takes me to this page which says how do
we add numbers now you might be provided
data which we can upload by loading a
file from our machine or getting data
from a web Source or even connecting to
a database so there are various options
which we will see in some time so here
we have an option which is called Data
you can click on this one and this
basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from SQL
Server from analysis services from odata
data feed you can get in from XML from
data connection Wizard or also from
Microsoft query you can be running in
different queries here which shows up in
the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use and
that basically will display all the
connections for this particular workbook
which we do not have as of now but we
can create them but let's look at simple
examples now you can follow these
instructions here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is from
which row to which row you would want to
add the data so for example I could just
do a sum here and that shows up all the
different functions which are available
then we can open up a parenthesis and we
can say I would be interested in
totaling the amount
from
column D and I would select for example
D4 so I could be doing this and then I
could say D4
onwards till d 7 so that's the data
which I'm interested in you can close
your parenthesis and hit enter and that
gives you the total there is also a
shortcut for this which you can always
do is we can first delete this and you
can just place your cursor here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime expand or basically
collapse so I will basically select this
which says this function needs two
numbers which is number one and number
two and then you can hit on enter and
that gives you the total so similarly we
can be getting in the data here by
selecting all the fields so here it also
says that you can use a shortcut now
what we can also do is we can add
numbers over 50 by selecting the yellow
cell here and then giving a condition
such as so I can basically use something
like sum if and then open a parenthesis
I can select I would be interested in
this row and then I can even drag and
drop
till here so that tells me the 11 to the
15 you can then put in a comma here and
you can give your condition say for
example we would say I would be
interested in numbers only above 50 and
we can select this
close your codes and then just close
your paranthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total as hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here I could select this now
there is also an option I can click on
home and I can go for something like
Auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says sum is alt plus
equals so it automatically adds up your
values and I can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then I can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
summer if formula here but add amounts
that are less than 100 and the result
should be 160. so what we can do is we
can basically select all the numbers
which are lesser than 100 so the way we
did earlier here there can be always a
shortcut so you can always for example
if you would want to avoid typing in the
formula you can always copy it from here
and then just hit on enter so you are
back into this cell and then I can
basically go here and paste the number
and then as per the requirement we are
required to select anything which is
lesser than 100 so what I could do is I
could select here I could say let's say
G and then I can change this value to
g15 and that's one more way now we see
our selected rows have been changed so I
can hit on enter and I can check what is
the result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so I will have to also change
this one to a lesser sign and that
basically gives me the total which is
160. so that's how you can simply add
numbers you can use autosum you can type
in the formula you can select the fields
or you can just place your cursor where
you would be looking for a sum and then
you can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at some easy options of
filling your cells or automatically
populating the values in your cells
within your Excel sheet now here we have
an option which says 100 now we can
click on this and that basically says it
is making a sum of column C4 to D4 so if
I click on this one I can check that
this is row number four which shows up
here and I also know this is column C I
also have D so this equals is basically
giving me a sum of C4 to D4 now what we
can do is we can always place our cursor
here at the right corner and then we can
just drag and drop and this basically
gives me a total of all the numbers for
all different rows so this is one
shortcut which we can do to get the
total Excel will automatically give the
totals which we call as filling down now
what we can do is in the same way if we
would want to get the totals here we can
first check what is this 200 and this
tells me this C11 to c14 total so it is
totaling the rows from C11 so column C
and 11th row till 14th row and that's
the sum now what I can also do is I can
similarly like above we can do a filling
right which basically means bringing
your cursor here and then just dragging
and dropping it all the way where you
would need the totals and this basically
gives me the total there is one more
quick way to check if this is right so
the easiest option would be to select
this cell now what I can also do is I
can just select all of these fields by
just highlighting and selecting all the
fields once it is selected press on Ctrl
R and that gives you the total now if we
would be doing this top down then I
could select all these rows for this
particular column and then I could do a
control D so that's your filling down
and this one was filling right so this
is an easier option of doing a fill when
you would want to have the formula
applied to every row as it occurs in the
first row or the last row we could test
this by for example selecting these
fields I could delete them and I have
here which says 130 I could just place
my cursor here and I could drag it all
the way up and that should also do the
same Magic which we were seeing from top
down so this is a simple way wherein you
can fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate or move your computation to
all the cells
let's look at the split option which
basically helps us in splitting the data
when we have some kind of pattern or
when we have some kind of delimiters in
our data in say one particular column
and we would want to derive the values
out of it so we can always use the
splitting option now the easiest option
would be so for example we have our
email column which has the email IDs and
which we can clearly see has a first
name dot last name now I see that there
is a last name Smith filled up here
first name is empty so what I can also
do is I can just type in say Nancy here
now that's the first name I can again
start typing the second name and as soon
as you do that you would see a faded
list of numbers and that's your clue to
hit enter and once you do that you would
see all the first names have been filled
in here if you would want to maintain
the case sensitiveness you can just go
ahead and delete these and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say Nancy as the
first name go down to the next cell and
just type in Andy and there is your
grade list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name what
we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now I can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking Ctrl Z and that's basically
gone what I can also do is I can select
a particular field and then I can go
into home option and under home you have
an option here which says fill so you
can select this and then you can do a
Flash Fill which is what we are doing
here so click on Flash Fill and that
automatically fills up the values so in
this way you can work within your
spreadsheet and you can be filling up
the values where a delimiter by default
is understood and we can split the data
now however sometimes you might have
some data which has a different kind of
delimiter and there is again a smarter
way of splitting your data so you can
always scroll down here and that says
splitting a column based on delimiters
so we have some values in the data
column and these values in each row are
separated by comma so
select this your data is already
selected text to columns delimited comma
I selected and now click on next so it
basically says what is the destination
let's select this one
and I can choose what would you want to
have so that shows me this would be my
data preview now I can basically select
this one I can say finish and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in in the columns appropriately
so this is how you can split your data
based on a delimiter and then organize
your data in a better way now there are
some Advanced options which we can learn
later but this basically tells about
using a formula so this is something if
say if we have some name in one cell and
if you would want to split it into first
name your helper column your middle name
last name so that can also be done using
formulas and this basically tells how
would you extract characters from your
left cell and how would you place them
in your right cell so you can try this
activity which is a little more of
advanced option the benefit is that you
can always use this
wherein if you do some kind of
transformation using your formulas if
your original data gets updated then the
split data will also get updated and
that's the benefit of using formulas
where you can place values from one cell
into multiple cells based on execution
of your details in the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your X and Y axis or as I would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become your rows
so what we can do is the simplest way is
you can select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and I would say two rows now I
can select all of these and then I can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt V that's a
shortcut what you can also do is once
you have selected all your Fields you
can just copy them so just do a Ctrl C
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special and once
you do that you need to select the
transpose option over here and click on
OK and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as a mount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed in this particular
format now there is another way of doing
that and again that's using your
formulas so what you can do is you can
transpose with a formula also and that
basically works when you have similar
kind of data so this has six columns and
basically two rows so you can basically
do this so you can select this and
earlier we were doing a copy but now
what we would want to do is we would
want to just look at the row numbers
which tells me it is c33 c34 and it
starts with c and ends in with your H
column so what we can do is we know that
we have six columns and two rows so
transposing that would actually give me
two columns and six rows so what we can
do is we can select two columns and six
rows in our Excel sheet I can then
basically start typing in the message or
I can just go to the address bar and
here I can say
transpose
let's go for c33 h34 it basically
selects my data and now I can just do a
control shift and enter and now if you
see all the values have been populated
now you can just place your cursor in
one of the cells but if you see the
address bar the formula Remains the Same
this is because this is an array formula
so we can read more about an array
formula here it's basically something
which performs calculations and on more
than one cell in an array and in the
example here the array is the original
data that is c33 to h34 so your
transpose is just changing the
horizontal orientation to the vertical
orientation so this is a very simple way
in which you can basically use the
excels capability to transpose your data
and convert your rows into columns and
columns into rows apart from working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data sorting the data or basically
splitting your data transposing your
data one of the other requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you are working
on huge data and you would want to sort
it in a particular order say ascending
or descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how Excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so let's check that
so if we're going to sort and filter and
say this is the data I have say for
example I would want to sort the values
in the department column alphabetically
so what I can do is I can select
Department admin column and I'm already
in the Home tab I can straight away go
here which says sort and filter I can
then say sort A to Z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column and once once I do
this you would see the data has been
sorted but it's not just this data we
can just do a control Z and check what
are the values we have so here we have
meet which is beef and ninety thousand
hundred ten thousand the values then you
have Bakery which should ideally be the
first row if we sort it in an
alphabetical order which goes with
Bakery as desserts you have the values
so we can check this again so select
department and then just do a sort and
filter and let's say sort A to Z and if
you see the data has changed but it's
not just in changing your First Column
but then it has taken care of all the
data however the data has been sorted it
based on the department column so you
have Bakery which aligns with deserts
which has the values and now we have all
the data which has been filtered now
what we can also do is we can sort
December's amounts from largest to
smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the December
column let's say 20 000 and then what I
can do is I can go into sort filter and
then I can say sort largest to smallest
so if you see Bakery breads is the row
which has the smallest data or maybe you
have daily sandwiches so that one looks
also smaller so let's do a larger to
smallest and if I do this you would see
the values have been shifted now so it
is no more based on the department
column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the December
column and you see Bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last so either you can sort the
data based on a department column which
goes based on the values these are all
string values or words so it sorts
alphabetically if you have numbers might
be you can give some values and you can
sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select if you would
want to select the data so I could do a
custom sort and then I could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the Sorting
needs to be done is it cell values is
its cell color font color conditional
formatting and then you can also choose
the order so that's one more way to do
that now if you scroll down that also
shows how you can sort by date or a
color so for example if you would want
to sort based on the expense date so
there are different options so what I
can do is I can select this date field I
can just do a right click I can go into
sort and then I can choose I would want
to sort oldest to newest so since I
selected the date field it basically has
sorted all the data data and it has
taken the expense date into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so I could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates I would be interested in looking
at I also have sort by color here I can
do a sort oldest or newest or newest to
oldest so I could also use these filters
which have been applied here now we have
the data which is in color so if I would
want to basically select the color
columns or color cells I could select
this I can basically do a right click
here and when I go into sort I could
choose put selected color or cell color
on the top and that basically will make
sure that my data is sorted and it has
also sorted that in a descending order
so in this way you can sort or basically
filter your data what we can also do is
we can add filters so sometimes we can
go for formulas which we would want to
use what we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here now how does the
filter come in there so if I would
select a particular row I could select a
particular row and then I could decide
if I would want to just add a filter to
this one and that's how the filter has
come in so we have the filter what we
can do is we can basically click on this
drop down and then you have something
like number filters so we can always go
here we can basically choose one of
these so we can basically choose above
average so I could select this and then
basically it shows me the values we
could also delete the filter by clicking
on this one and we could say well I'm
not interested in this filter anymore
so I could clear the filter and that
shows me all the values or I could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food I can go in here I can go
into number filters and then I could say
well I'm interested in values which are
below average above average might be
greater than and then I can choose what
is the value so for example if we say I
am interested in food which is greater
than 25 dollars I could give a value
here I could say okay and now I have
applied the filter similarly you can
select this and then you can just clear
your filter and your data is back so
remember no data is lost
it is just hidden or basically based on
the filter not shown so that's good
enough for us and in this way you can
sort and filter the data so for more
details obviously in all the sheets you
have the links which point to more
information on the web and you can
always refer to these so this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data which has been stored
within your Excel within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering it will also be good to learn
how to work with tables or basically
converting your data into a tabular
format and then doing some easy
computations so click on this tables
option here now here we see there is
some data which is in five columns and N
number of rows so I can basically select
this data and then what I can do is I
can insert choose the table option and
then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that I'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learned earlier
how to use and this is basically my
table which is a collection of cells
which has some special features so we
can easily add rows to this table we can
add columns to this table and we can
even do some calculations so for example
here I can click on this one I can
basically enter some field and then I
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example I
would say chocolates
I could give some value here so I 25
000 might be 35
000 and then basically I can given some
values here now what you can also do is
you can continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this
option here in the top bottom right
corner you can just drag it towards the
right and that basically has
automatically created columns for my
next months wherein I can feed in the
data so this is a simpler way wherein
you can keep adding more rows and
columns to your data if that has been
converted in a tabular format now let me
just do a control Z that basically
deletes the columns again Ctrl Z deletes
the last row which we added and I can
stop here or I can even remove my values
by doing multiple control Z and removing
my rows so this is how I converted my
data into a table and then I can easily
work on this what I can also do is I can
do some calculations so what we can do
we have a table here we have a total
field and what we can do is we can just
select one cell here now as we have
learned earlier we can do a alt and then
equals and that basically says what is
this doing so it says it is calculating
the sum of the last three months and if
that's what you would want to do just
hit on enter and it has automatically
calculated the totals for all your rows
for these three columns so the sum
formula is getting filled up now I can
select any particular cell and I can
look in my address bar so it has already
given me the formula where it has
started calculating the sum from the
October column till the December column
and has given me the calculated values
of the columns what we can also do is we
can get total rows in the table now
that's a simpler option so what we can
do is we can select any l in this
particular table
and then we see that there is a table
tools design option showing up here now
I can select this and then it says well
let's get a total row so let's select
this and it automatically populates the
total here and if you would want the
average then we could select this and
from the drop down I can select what I'm
interested in so for example I would
want the average values and not the
total I could just select this and that
gives me the average of these values so
we can always do simpler computations
here by converting our data into table
format let's learn about one more
efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here now say for example
you have this data which has the values
in the food column and department is
empty and say for example you would want
to enter the values in Department
however you would want to select the
department should either have produce or
meet and bakery and these are the only
three options which should be available
for any user to fill in the values how
do we do that so we can basically create
a table by pressing Ctrl D so what I can
do is under my department
here I can select one of the cells and
then I can do a control T that basically
converts this into a table I can say
okay and my table is created now what I
can do is once this part is done
we can select all the blank Fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable now under your data tab you
can go in and select data validation and
this has an option called Data
validation click on this which basically
says allow any value so here I will
select I would want to give a list of
values and then I can type in my values
here which I can say produce say for
example meet and then say Bakery now
these are the values so we can click on
OK
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to Apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so I can go into every cell and
then I can basically choose what is the
department which handles this and then
basically I can select one of these from
the drop down so this is an easier
option of creating your drop down and
then feeding in the values from the set
of values which you have defined here on
the right so this is a simple example of
using your drop downs working with your
tables working with your sort and filter
transpose split filling up your data
adding in some data here and similarly
you can use Excel for more than one use
case using its inbuilt features to
easily work with your data let's see how
we can import data or bring in data into
our Excel from your local machine or
from an external web source so what we
can do is we can open up a blank Excel
sheet and say for example you have been
provided a text file or a CSV file and
you would want to import that data into
your Excel sheet that can be easily done
so right now I've opened an
Excel sheet now I can click on data and
here I have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources so or you can click on
connections if you have already created
some so we can click on from other
sources so this is one option where you
can connect to your different data
sources and you can get the data from
one of these what we can also do is I
can click on connections now it says
there is none I can click on ADD it says
well show the connections where
connection files or Network
connection files on this computer so I
can say let's get some files from this
computer now if that does not show up
something so say browse for more and
that basically shows you different
options so let's basically select a
folder where I have some data sets I'll
click in here and this is basically a
folder where I have some data sets now
let me select this particular file and I
know it is a CSV file so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a DOT CSV file which is what we
are interested in so I'll take this file
I'll say open now this basically shows
me the text import wizard option which
says is the file delimited I'll say yes
click on next so I will select comma as
my delimiter I can say text qualifier is
none now this is my data so my data
preview is already showing me the data
is what is the data in the CSV file you
can click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is General
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so I'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here so we basically have this and now I
can click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data which we have here the
connection which we have created say
open and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on OK and now this
data is automatically inserted in my
Excel file I can basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what I
can do is I can go into my GitHub and
let's say I would be interested in this
CSV file so I can select this and this
is my GitHub path a path on web so I can
click on draw and that basically gives
me the raw path where this particular
file is now you can select this copy
this particular path and here you can
come back to your Excel sheet we would
be interested in getting the data from
web might be from a text file where we
will have to specify the delimiters or
let's go to web and here I can given the
web path from where I would be
interested in getting the file let's
give the GitHub path which is publicly
available and then click on import now
once you click on import it tells me
that two Fields data and value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on OK and now you have the data
coming in but then this basically shows
me in one particular field so what we
can also do is we can just do a control
a that selects all my columns here and
that's my data so we can then basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next we
can select comma and let the text
qualifier be codes
it shows me data preview click on next
so you have the general format it shows
the destination that's the column click
on finish and now your data has been
split and you have the data which you
have imported from web so this is the
data which is coming in from web this is
the data which came in from my local
machine and similarly we can even create
connection with an existing database so
I can basically click on connections if
I would want to do that so I have an
option called connection here and it
says where the selected connections are
used I can basically click on ADD I can
basically choose if I would want to get
the files from Network or from computer
like we did earlier I can click on
browse for more which should show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new SQL Server Connection you can
connect to a new data source coming in
from different place you could basically
choose what kind of connection you would
you want so these are all the different
options which we can go for and we can
basically connect to a database for
example if I have some database and say
for example access database
I can see if there are some files with
that particular database and I can
import it so similarly we can also uh
click in here which says new query and
that also gives you an option of getting
the data from your files from all these
folders from databases so you can
basically click here and then you can
import data from a mySQL database
provided that is set up on your local
machine or on a particular server you
can go from cloud you can get it from
online services you can get it from
other sources which says from web from
your Hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor you can get the
data from different sources and then you
can bring it into your Excel so in this
way you can get your data from different
sources into your Excel into your
spreadsheet and then you can continue
working on those data sets
we have already learned some basic
operations which you can do in Excel and
let's Implement our knowledge by working
on this particular data which is coming
in from housing data set now here if we
see some fields we have agent date
listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been sorted
in newest to oldest order of date listed
so how do we
arrive at this so what I can do is I can
just click on data listed and then I can
either go in here I can select sort I
can get into custom sort and then I can
choose the column based on which I would
want to sort the data so I would look
for the newest data to the oldest data
that means that would be in a descending
order of dates or you could say the
oldest state or the earliest month will
be towards the lower side of your sheet
so here we can select date listed now I
can say let it sort based on Cell values
and the order what we have here so we
have newest to oldest so let's select
this I can say OK and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see an earlier month hour and
earlier month than that in the state
listed so we have sorted our data into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your date column so the result shows
up here now what we can also do is we
can have different questions which we
would want to answer so for example I
would want to sort the data in ascending
order of area and descending order of
agent name how do we do that so let's
look into this so this is here I already
have the result here and how did I get
this so I'm looking for ascending order
of area and descending order of agent
name so we can start with any particular
column that does not matter so for
example if I look into this Excel sheet
I have my agent name select this which
we want in a descending order so we
could either do a sort and then go for
descending sort Z to A we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or I could just say
sort Z to A and then it has arranged the
data based on the agent column being in
descending order now I can go into area
and then I can again do a sort and I
wanted my area column to be used for
sorting the data and ascending to
descending and that basically not only
changes the order of this particular
column but for my complete data so let's
do that and now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so we can see
how many values we have here and the
area values which we see and this is how
you get your result so I'll just do a
control Z and again and I'm back to my
original data and this is the sorted
result which we are seeing at similarly
we can answer other questions for
example sort the data according to the
following order of area that is we are
saying counties
Central and then your county so we can
basically choose in which particular way
we would want to do it so it is County
Central and then again County so if I
look into my sheet 3 so here I basically
have my data which is having some South
County then you have your Central and
then you have your North County so we
would want to sort the data to solar
problem which is according to the
following order so first we go for area
then we go for South County Central and
North County so what we can do is we can
basically have area field selected and I
would want to sort this particular data
so I have South County Central and North
County so I can basically go for custom
sort
and then I can choose which is the value
or column which I'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like cell
values well you can also try to explore
conditional formatting icon if this is
what you would want to use or we can
basically go for just cell values and
here we can say if I would be interested
in first getting my values for South
County so for example I can say custom
list and then I can basically given the
new list here so I can say s
Dot County
and then I would want Central and then I
would want North County
so let's select this
as it exists we can basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with Kelly you have in the 12th
row something like Lang and that's what
we are doing so we can basically arrange
the data in a particular order by
choosing a custom list and then sorting
your data so that's one more simpler
task where we what we have done where we
have sorted the data in the order where
under our area column we first wanted
South County then we wanted Central data
and then we wanted North County so this
is how you can do it now let's look into
one more problem so it says find all the
houses in the central area and we would
want to basically apply a regular filter
let's let's see how do we do that so we
can click on this and here we have the
data so the problem statement is we
would want to find all the houses in
Central Area now how do we do that we
can do a sorting but we would want to
use the filter which you see here is
implemented so how do you do it so you
can select this area and say for example
I would want to apply filter I can just
go in here and I can say let's get a
filter on my first row and now I have
filters applied so we are interested in
looking into the Central Area houses
let's go in here it says all these
fields are selected that means it shows
everything wherein your area has all
these values let's unselect this and
then I will only be interested in the
central so let's say okay and then say
okay so now you see that the area filter
has been applied and we are looking at
the central column so what we have done
is we have applied a simple filter and
we are looking at our data at any point
of time if you do not want the filter
then what I can do is I can select this
and I can say well I'm interested in all
the data so I could do this or you can
clear the filters from area and you get
your data back so that's in one way you
can filter out your data so let's look
at an example of sort and filter where
we might have to filter the data based
on two columns or multiple columns with
different kind of values where it could
be and and or condition now say for
example this is the data I have and this
is the question which we need to answer
such as find the list of all houses in
the central region with pool and South
County without pool now if it was a
simple filter based on one cell I could
have just selected my header row I could
have then applied the filter
and once I have the filter I can look in
area where I have three regions so I'm
only interested in Central and South
County so I can get rid of North County
and that's fine but then we have two
different conditions here so we need the
data in central region to have the value
for pool being true
and for South County the value has to be
without pool now how do we do that so
what we can do is we can first create a
copy of these headers here so let me do
that now the area has to be South County
so basically I can either just select
this and I can choose this value
and then I can select this and then I
can choose Central so that's the
criteria which I have and the pool value
has to be so central region should be
with pool so then this one
basically has to be true
and this one has to be basically false
so south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now to get my result we
can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is M column and
eighth row okay so we would want the
result here so let's go ahead and now
click on data and then in filter you
have an option called Advanced and here
what I can do is I can say I would want
to filter the list in the place but
that's not what I would want to do so
I'll say copy to another location and
here if you see the list range will tell
me that this is the data so A1 to J 126
so a to J column selected and all the
rows
criteria range is basically based on
what I have given here so that is m
from 1
to V which is 3
so I'm selecting these columns and then
I am saying all the way whatever
criteria I have given and copy 2 I am
saying M8
to V8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay and now I have my data
which has been filtered and I have my
area which is South County that is
without Pool Central with pool again
South County without pool and then if
you look at your central value that's
pool so this is an advanced filter which
we have applied where simply we have
filtered the data based on two columns
and then we have our result so in this
way you can have your customized filter
applied on two different columns and get
your data which can be either replacing
the existing content or in the same
sheet in different set of columns and
rows you can have your result let's look
at one more example of filtering where
you are trying to filter the data data
based on a and condition condition being
met in two different columns and then
you would want to filter out the data
for only specific columns so the
situation is the agents with a house in
North County that should be County area
having two and a single type family so
we are talking about two bedrooms and we
would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that if
we would want to only populate these
columns which is Agent area bedroom and
type now what you can do is as I
explained earlier that you can get your
result in the same sheet in a different
location so here I have created these
headers which says agent area bedrooms
and type now this is basically a copy of
all the columns what we have here agent
data listed area list Place bedrooms
bath square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
Advanced criteria to filter the data so
the conditions which need to be met is
we need to look at North County so for
example here in area I can basically go
ahead and select one of the values North
County now the criteria is having two
bedrooms only so let's say bedrooms and
let's say the value should be 2
and then basically I am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type I
can give the criteria single type so
this is my and condition so we are
saying North County area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if I select this this one tells me
that this is m one row onwards till V
2 so this is what we have and we would
want to filter based on this so let's go
ahead and then go for data filter
Advanced and here in advanced it says
filter the list in place now that's not
what we would want to do so I'll say
copy to another location this basically
selects the list range so which is
telling me A1
2 J 126 so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on M1 V2 which we have given
here and copy to I would say for example
from M7
two
P seven now this is the area where I
would this is the place where I want the
result let's say okay and now I get my
data which is based on the question
which has been asked that you would want
the agents with a house in North County
area having two bedrooms and single type
family so in this way you can basically
do Advanced filtering get your data and
get it stored in the sheet anywhere at a
different location well I could have
also done filtering in place and that
would have replaced the data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some Advanced filtering we can
also use Excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say using some numerical
filters now here say for example the
problem statement is that you would want
to display all the houses whose list
price is between
000 to 600 000 or say for example we
would want to filter out the data to
something else say for example let's say
I have I would want to filter out the
data between 300
000 and 400 000 so we can basically
update this say for example I am saying
I am interested in 300
to
400. 1000 and that's the criteria to
filter out the data now there are two
different ways or there are two easier
ways to do it one is I would want to
look at the list price so I can select
this I can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy you can click on this
one and then you can go into number
filters and you can choose between now
that's one easier way of doing it so I
could basically select this I could say
I am looking for Value which is greater
than or equal to three hundred thousand
and then is less than or equal to 400
000 so if I just do this I have applied
my filter and I have my data which is
filtered based on my criteria right so
that's one easier way of doing it or let
me do a control Z
now let the filter be there which you
can anyways use but what we can also do
is as we have seen earlier methods so
get a
set or get your column headers here
and then you are giving two columns here
now the only difference between
my
this set of columns which I have one two
three four and then you have 7 and 10
columns and if you see here we have 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you want
a and condition you will basically
add the columns where I can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
or condition would lie in a different
line now here I can give this value so I
am looking for listed price being
between 300 000 so I am saying it should
be greater than or equal to 300
000 and then I can say less than or
equal to 400
000 now that's my criteria and then I
need my result here which is in M 7 so
what I can do is once I have given my
criteria which I'll be using to filter I
can get into Data I can go ahead into
advanced and then I can say copy to
another location so it is selecting my
A1 to J 126 criteria range is based on
M1 to W 2 and then I would want my
result from this particular column so
let's say okay and now you have your
data filtered out in a different
location in the sheet which has been
filtered based on your and condition so
you can filter out the data in this way
or you could just apply a filter on a
column and give the conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
Excel where we would have an and and an
or condition so say for example this is
the data given to you and the question
is that you would want to find all the
houses in North County again that's a
spelling mistake but then they are North
County area with a list price greater
than 300 000 and having three or four
bedrooms so the bedroom has conditional
so it has R 3 and 4 and then basically
you have list price which is greater
than 300 000 now I could have obviously
selected The Columns and then basically
gone for a filter so I can just do a
filtering here and then I'm looking for
list price being greater than 300 000 so
which we can always give a number filter
and I can say great greater than and
then I can say greater than or equal so
I can say greater than and then I can
give 3030 300 000 and that's basically
the filter which we would want and here
I would want to select the bedrooms
which should be just either three or
four so if for example here I go in here
and I unselect this and then I say 3 and
4 right so I am getting my data which is
greater than 300 000 and it should have
the bettering values which will be
either 3 or 4 selected now that's one
way of doing it let's do a control Z and
get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear filter so you get your data back
as it was so what we can do is we can
hear
give the criteria so for example I have
my list price now this is what I would
want as a condition so let's say greater
than three hundred thousand
300 000 and bedrooms should be three
and then I can say greater than 300 000
and then I can say 4 so this one
basically gives me a situation where
your list price has to be greater than
300 000 and bedroom should be either
three or four so we have given our
filtering criteria now to get the result
what we can do is we can go into Data we
can go into advanced and we can say copy
to another location so our list range is
selected which is columns a to J row
number 1 to 126 your criteria range is
given in M1 to V3 where we have
specified and we are saying the result
would be in M 7 to V7 so if I do this
now I have got the same data which we
were seeing earlier and here the bedroom
values are three or four and basically
the list price is greater than three
hundred thousand so this is a simpler
way in which you can create your filters
and all this Advanced filtering what we
are seeing it it will be saved with your
sheet you can always go back and change
this value or you could do filtering
where one person has to look into the
filter to see what values have been
selected now let's understand what is a
formula in Excel
in Microsoft Excel a formula is an
expression that operates on values in a
range of cells all formulas in Excel
written a result even when the result is
an error
there are different ways to handling
errors which we'll see later
formulas allow you to perform basic
calculations such as addition
subtraction multiplication and division
you can also find out percentages and
average for a range of cells manipulate
date and time and lots more
now let me open an Excel spreadsheet and
show you what a formula is
so here I have my Excel worksheet
now let's see
I have some values under this e column C
20 30 and 40.
now I want to write a formula that will
add the values that are present from
cell A1 to cell A3 so I'll give an equal
to sign
and give my
cell range that is E1 plus E2 plus A3
now if I hit enter it will give me the
addition of 20 plus 30 plus 40 which is
90.
now let's say
I want to divide
for T by 30
if I hit enter it will give me the
division of 40 by 30 which is 1.33 now
let's see what a function is in Excel
when you're working in Excel you will
often hear the terms formula and
function used frequently and sometimes
interchangeably
they are closely related but not exactly
the same technically a formula is an
expression that begins with an equal
sign functions are used to perform
complex calculations that cannot be done
manually
functions have names that reflect their
intended use
now let me take you back to the Excel
sheet
and I'll show you what a function is
suppose
now I want to add the values ranging
from A1
to A4
either you can use a formula like we did
here we wrote a formula using multiple
addition operator but there is another
way which you can use
that is to write a function
so Excel provides a function called sum
that allows you to select a range of
cells so I'll select E1 to A4
and close the bracket and if I hit enter
it will return me the result of 20 plus
30 plus 40 plus 90 which is 180.
similarly there are other functions
let's say I want to find the average of
a range of cells so you can use the
average function to do that
if I hit tab it will auto complete I'll
select the same range of cells from A1
to E4 and close the bracket if I hit
enter it will return me the average of
these selected cells which is 45. now
that you have understood the basics of
formulas and functions in Excel let's
dig deeper into learning the different
types of functions available in Excel
and use relevant formulas when needed
along the journey on your screens you
can see we have a mathematical functions
worksheet where we will learn the
different mathematical functions present
in Excel
let's begin at looking at the simple
table
that has three columns the quantity
column price per unit and total sales
now let's find the product of quantity
and price per unit to get the total
sales value for that we will write a
formula using the multiplication
operator so here I'll write the formula
I'll give an equal to sign I'll select
the first quantity
multiplication operator and then select
my price per unit
and if I hit enter it will give me the
product of quantity and price per unit
so 10 into 30 is 300 now to copy that
formula I will just drag this down
you can see we have all our total sales
values now
if you want to find the sum of total
sales
you can use the sum function so here
I'll write equal to then use the sum
function I'll open the bracket then I'll
select my total sales values close the
bracket and I hit enter
it will give me the total sales or the
sum of sales
similarly
if you want to find the average of total
sales
you can use the average function so I'll
type average and hit tab it will auto
complete
I'll select my sales values close the
bracket if I hit enter it will give me
the average total sales now there's
another function called sum product that
is available in Excel you can use the
sum product function to return the sum
of the product of corresponding ranges
or arrays
so let's find the total sales using the
sum product function
the first array we will have the
quantity values while the second array
will have the price per unit
so I'll
select my sum product function
my first array I'll give the quantity
values I'll give a comma
and I'll select my second array that is
price per unit I'll close the bracket
hit enter you can see we have the total
sales value that is
1165. now moving ahead let's understand
the types of logical functions in Excel
and how you can use it
to the extreme left you can see there
are a number of logical functions I have
noted here so you have is even function
Resort function is logical and so on
now let's use them one by one and see
how it works
there is even function returns true if
the given number is an even value and it
returns false if it's not an even number
so we have here two numbers 4 and 13
now
if I want to check if 4 is an even
number or not I can use the A7 function
so I'll give equal to sine
and type is even
and I'll select this number or the cell
close the bracket if I hit enter it will
return true because 4 is an even number
similarly if I have to check for 13
I'll write is even
and select the cell which is A3 close
the bracket
I'll hit enter it will return false
because 13 is not an even number
similarly
the is odd function returns true if the
given number is odd and it returns false
if it's not an odd number so let's check
if 4 is an odd number or not
so I'll write is odd
tab
then I'll select this cell
close the bracket hit enter it returns
false because 4 is not an odd number
similarly
let's check for 13 I'll write is odd
select A7 which has 13
I'll hit enter it returns true because
13 is an odd number now
next we have the is logical function
this logical function returns true if
the given value is a logical value and
it returns false if it's not a logical
value
when I say logical value I mean true or
false now let's check if 30 is a logical
value or not
so I'll write equal to is logical
I'll select 30.
if I hit enter it returns false because
30 is not a logical number
similarly let's check for the next two
values
I'll select this cell value which has
true in it
if I hit enter it returns true because
true in itself is a logical value
similarly false should also return true
because it's a logical value
you can see it here then
we have is number function that returns
true if the given value is a number s
could be integers floating values or
whole numbers now we have a number here
which is 40.5 let's verify if it's a
number or not so I'll write equal to
then select is number
select the cell close the bracket hit
enter it returns true
similarly you have to check if 30 is a
number or not
you can use the same function which is
is number
select 30 close the bracket hit enter it
returns true because 30 is also a number
now
in the next cell we have a text value
you can see it's CNN so ideally it
should return false because CNN
is not a number there you go it has
returned false because CNN is a text
value and not a number now let's explore
a few other functions that you can see
here so the round function rounds a
number to a specified number of digits
so suppose I want to round up
35.316 to 2 decimal places so I'll write
equal to
and I'll give the round function
I'll provide my number 35.316
comma since I want to round up to two
decimal places I'll give two
I'll close the bracket if I hit enter
it gives me the rounded value of 35.316
which is 35.32 now the round down
function rounds a number down towards 0.
so let's see
I'll give the round down function
and I'll provide the same number that is
35.316
let's say
I want to round down to two decimal
places
if I hit enter the result is 35.31
similarly the round of function rounds a
number up away from 0 so I'll write
round up
I'll give my number 35.316
if I give the number of digits say 2
it will return
35.32 so it rounds up this value moving
ahead
now if you want to convert a number into
integers you can do that using the int
function
so suppose I want to convert 35.316 into
integers I can
give my integer function that is int
and provide by number 35.316
close the bracket if I hit enter
so you have the integer value of this
floating Point number
similarly if you want to find the
integer of say equal to int
let's say a negative number minus 35.316
it will return the negative integer
value that is minus 36.
now the truncate function truncates a
number to an integer by removing the
decimal of fractional part of a number
so let's say I want to truncate 35.316
I'll write
trunk
which is the truncate function
now let me pass in my number that is
35.316 let's say I want to give the
number of digits as 2
and close the bracket hit enter it
returns me
35.31 so it has truncated the last digit
now similarly
if I
if the number of digits as 1 the result
will be 35.3
you can see it here moving ahead
the ceiling function rounds a number up
that is to the nearest multiple of
significance so I'll show you what it
means I'll use equal to then pass in my
ceiling function
I'll give my number 35.316
if I give say 2
close the return Smith 36 because the
nearest highest multiple of this number
is 36. similarly if I give
let's say 5 it will return 40 because
the nearest highest multiple of this
number to 5 is 40.
now
talking about the floor function
the floor function rounds a number down
to the nearest multiple of significance
so for example if I
use the floor function
and the same number
35.316 now let's say I want to give the
significance as 2 it will return 34 the
nearest lowest multiple of this number
that is divisible by 2 is 34.
now if you want to change this number
from 2 to let's say we want to give us 7
if I hit enter it will give 35 because
35 is the nearest
multiple of 7 next let's talk about an
important function called subtotal now
subtotal Returns the subtotal in a list
or database the sub maximum minimum sum
and others let's explore a few of this
let's see
I want to use subtotal function
and let's say I want to find
average you can see here one is for
average I'll give one comma
I'll give my reference
this quantity column values
close the bracket if I hit enter
will give me the average of the selected
cells from
E2 to E4 now
let's say I want to find the subtotal
and this time I want to let's say I want
to count so I'll give 2 comma
I'll count all the values present in the
selected cells
from E2 to Z4 and close the bracket hit
enter it returns me 9 you can see there
are nine cells that are filled in here
next let's say this time I want to find
the subtotal and let's take some now so
I'll give 9 comma
let's sum up the price per unit column
so F2 to F4 close the bracket hit enter
you can see the sum of price per unit is
105.
now let's do one more
use the same subtotal function
now let's say I want to find the maximum
value
from the sales column select my total
sales column
close the bracket
write enter returns me 480 because
that's the highest or the maximum value
of total sales
now Excel provides a factorial function
called fact so if you want to find the
factorial of a number you can use this
function
so find out the factorial so I'll use
the fact function
let's say I want to find the factorial
of number 5
I'll close it
can see the factorial of 5 is 120
similarly if you want to find the
factorial
of let's say the number 7
it returns me 1 0 4 0. moving on now you
can use the Max and Min function to find
the maximum and minimum values in a
range of cells so I'll use the max
function let's say I want to find the
maximum from price per unit you can see
it has returned me the value that is 40.
similarly you can use the Min function
I'll use the same column price per unit
now you can see the minimum value from
price per unit column is 30. Excel also
has a function called Rand between that
returns a random number between the
numbers you specify so if you want to
Generate random numbers you can use 5
Square the result should be 25 you can
see it here
now I want to find the power of 4 raised
to 4
the result is 256. moving ahead the
Midas function or the mod function
Returns the remainder when a number is
divided by a divisor so let's see how to
use it I'll use the mod function
and give my number 10
let's divide 10 by 3 the result is 1.
now we have a few other numbers let's
try them also
use mod 12 let's say I want to divide 12
by 4
the result is 0 bit 9 similarly let's
see one more
I'll use the count function now let's
see I'll select from G1 to G4 if I close
the bracket hit enter it returns Me 3
because total sales the first cell value
is not a number it's a character value
hence it's skipped the count of total
sales and it counted the remaining cells
now next moving on to count a function
the count a function counts the number
of cells in a Range that are not empty
so for example if I use the county
function now let's say I'll select
from L1 to L4
it has returned Me 3 because we had an
empty cell so it skipped that count and
it counted the remaining cells that were
non-empty similarly let's use the
function once more and type count a now
let's say I'll select from L2 to n 4
close the bracket hit enter it gives me
5 because we have only 5 values that are
dels are empty so it skipped that count
moving ahead we have the count blank
function now as the function suggests it
counts the number of blank or empty
cells in a specified range of so if I
use count blank and let's say I'll
select
this range from L1 to L4 close the
bracket
you can see it has returned 1 because we
had one empty cell
in this range of cells now let's do one
more count blank
I'll select
from L2 to n 4
close the bracket it has returned 4
because we you can see it here we have
three blank cells here's a total four
hence it has returned 4. up next
we have the and function
the and function checks if all the
conditions or arguments are true
it returns true if all the conditions
are true if one of the conditions is
false then and function will return
false let's do this with an example
suppose I
write the and function
so the first argument or the parameter
has to be a logical
condition let's say I'll select from
E2 to E4
and my condition will be
greater than 9 let's say my second
condition
is from F2 to F4
is less than
45 close the bracket hit it returns true
because you can see our first condition
from E2 to E4 all the values are greater
than 9
while the second condition from F2 to F4
all the values are less than 45 so since
both the conditions at one of the values
is not less than 450 you can see we have
a value 480 which is greater than 450
and
our second condition F2 to F4 all the
values are greater than 25 now since one
of the conditions is false so and
function returns false moving on to R
function
the or function checks whether any of
the arguments are true and returns true
if all the arguments do not meet the
condition it will return false so you
have to satisfy all the conditions
in order to return a True Value I'll use
the or function now let's say I'll give
my condition from E2 to E4 greater than
15 comma from F2 to let's say F4 less
than 25 I close the bracket I hit enter
it has written me false because both the
arguments are not satisfying the
condition you can see from E2 to E4 none
of the values are greater than 15 and
similarly
from F2 to F4
none of the values are less than 25 now
since both the conditions are false are
or statement false let us take one more
example I'll use the r function again
now the condition will be from G2 to G4
greater than equal to 300 comma let's
say from F2 to F4 less than equal to 40.
I'll hit enter there you go it has
returned us true because both the
conditions are true conceive all the
values between G2 to G4 are greater than
or equal to 300 similarly all the values
from F2 to F4 are less than or equal to
40. now let's get to our second tab
which is character text functions here
we will learn various character
functions and how you can use them in
Excel so first you can see we have is
text function so the is text function
checks if the given value is a text
value and returns true or false so if I
were to check if this value is a text or
not so I can use the is text function
I'll give reference to this cell close
the bracket it returns false because 10
is not a text it's a number similarly
let's check the next one I'll select
cell E3 if I hit enter you can see it
has written true though the value is 10
but still it's a text the reason is you
can see on top we have given an apostop
before writing 10 so I'll show it to you
here in case I write 90 hit enter the
numbers by default are right aligned now
if I give an apost off and then write 90
hit enter it is now a text you can check
that using the x is text function select
the cell close the bracket hit enter it
returns me true so this 90 is a text
value now similarly let's check for the
next one is equal to is text
I'll select the cell hit enter it
returns me true because Excel is a text
value now the next function we have is
the length function
as the name suggests the length function
Returns the number of characters in a
string so it will count the total
characters including spaces as well as
special characters so let's see how many
characters does this string India has
if I hit enter it returns 5 You Can
Count India has in total 5 characters
similarly
let's check
for this sentence
I'll write Len which is the length
function
select this cell close the bracket hit
enter
it returns me 28 because it has counted
the spaces also now this is a function
called text that converts a value to
text in a specified number format so
suppose I want to convert these date
values into text values in a given
number format so I can write the text
function I can give the value by
referencing this cell comma let's say I
want to print the date value in the form
of a text in this format let's say DD mm
and Y by close the bracket you can see
this has converted the date value into
ddmm YY
now similarly you can change the date
value to text in some other format like
d d Triple M then 4y and see it returns
30 June
2015.
now if this is a text value or not you
can use the same function that is its
text I'll give reference to the cell
there you go it has returned me true
which means it has converted the date
values into text now moving ahead next
we have the replace function the replace
function replaces the part of a text
string within a different text string so
suppose I want to replace cell a 15
value which is a101 I'll give my start
numbers 1
the number of characters let's say one
and my new text I want to replace the a
value with B close the bracket if I hit
enter you can see here a101 has become
B101 because we replace the first a
value to B now let's try out a few more
examples I'll use the replace function
I'll give my old text that is
that is a102 I'll give my start number
as 1 my number of characters as one
let's say the new text I want is A2
close the bracket you can see it here
from our old text which had a it has
replaced with new text that has A2 now
let's say I want to use the replace
function over Adam I'll select this cell
a17 now let's see I the start number is
1 the number of characters is let's say
2 and I want my new character as s a
close the bracket you can see it here
the first two characters from Adam has
been replaced by S A that is what we did
here so we started our start num with
one then we chose the next two
characters that is a d and a d we
replaced it with S A so the name becomes
Sam now moving ahead the next function
we have is substitute
The Substitute function replaces
existing text with new text in a text
string for example if I use the
substitute function I'll give my old
text which has I work at simply learn
give a comma now I'll select let's say I
work which is from my old text and I
want to replace it with
he works
close the bracket
you can see
The Substitute function has replaced has
replaced the second 2010 from our old
string to 2016. next let's use the
substitute function once again I'll give
the cell reference as e22
this time I want to replace
2010 present in the old text to 2016.
you can see here at two places there
were 2010 it has replaced we to 2016 at
both the places then we have the
concatenate function you can see it here
concatenate means combining strings so a
concatenate function join submerges
several text strings into one text
string here I have two strings hello
and in another cell I have world I want
to concatenate these two strings
so I'll use the
concatenate function I'll select cell
e25
give a comma now I'll give two inverted
commas with a space give another comma
and select cell B25 that has called
close the bracket there you go now it
has concatenated both hello and world
now it's one word hello world similarly
let's concatenate these two cells I'll
use the concatenate function and select
my first cell that has XL is
now you can use an Amber sent to
concatenate as well and then give to
inverted commas for space give another
Ampersand and select the next cell close
the bracket hit enter you can see it has
concatenated
the two cells and it has formed a
sentence Excel is fun to learn up next
we have the repeat function
now repeat function or rept function
repeats text a given number of times you
can fill a cell with a number of
instances of a text string we have some
data here so here let's say these are
the age groups of women and there was a
survey these are the number of
respondents we got from each each group
I want to create an histogram I can use
the repeat function or rept function I
want to give my text as a special
character
and hit a comma and I'll select cell b32
which is the number of times I want to
repeat that character hit enter you can
see it has repeated the special
character 10 times now similarly you can
do it for the next few cells also if I
just copy paste this formula it will
give me the result so you can see it
looks like a histogram now let's say I
want to repeat hashtag and add the rate
symbol for 10 times so I can write the
repeat function give my text as hashtag
and add the rate and the number of times
I want is 10
close the bracket it returns me the
result which has hashtag and at the rate
printer 10 times moving ahead next we
have the type function now the type
function returns an integer representing
the data type of a value now here on the
right you can see suppose the type
function returns 1 it means the value is
a number or it's a blank let's say the
return type is 2 it means the data type
is a text if it's 4 it means the data
type is a logical value that is either
true or false now if it's an error it
will return the value 16 and if it's an
array it will return 64. now let's try
these examples
here we have Excel
which is a text value
so if I use my type function and select
Excel hit enter it returns me true
because Excel is a text value you can
see it here if it's a text it will
return to similarly let's try this one
hundred it has returned me 1 because 1
is a number so it will return me 1
15.45 if I use the type function 15.45
hit enter so it has returned me one now
you can see these are some errors now
it's an error because we have divided a
39 by A40 you can see it here E39 at a
text value and A4 T had a numeric value
so you cannot obviously divide a text by
a number so it has written me an error
now if I want to check the type close
the bracket hit enter it has returned me
16 you can see it here if it's an error
value it will return six similarly this
one more error here let's try this out
use the type function give this error
hit enter this also has returned 16. now
let's check one more example for an
array now you can write an array inside
the type function itself to write an
array we use curly braces I'll give one
comma 2 comma 3 and 4 as my array
elements
I close the curly braces and the bracket
but hit enter it has returned me 64. you
can see it here if it's an array it will
return the data type as 64. which is an
array now
there's a function called is blank which
checks if a cell is empty or blank if it
is empty it will return true else it
will return false
now if you were to check
if this cell is empty or not
if I hit enter it turns me true because
you can see it here cell a47
is empty and there's no value in it
now if I want to find out
if Cell e 48 is blank or not if I hit
enter it returns me false because there
is a value for t in it
now
we'll see how to use trim function so
the trim function removes all the
unnecessary spaces from a string but it
won't remove the sink all the
unnecessary spaces except the space
between Angela and Stevens now I'll copy
paste this value to the remaining cells
you can see it has removed all the
unnecessary spaces from the original
string
now you can check the length once again
for the trimmed string if I hit enter
the length is 15 for our defense you can
see it has removed at least six spaces
from the original string now let's copy
paste this formula it has removed the
unnecessary spaces from all the original
strings next we have the find function
so the find function Returns the
starting position of one string within
another string now you should notice
that find function is case sensitive so
let's use defined function here I'll
write find I want to find where capital
S is located in the cell A52 that has
Angela's defense into the comma select
A52 hit enter it returns me the starting
position that is 11 now if I were to
check using the find function this time
I want to find where small e is located
within A52 which has Angela Stevens I'll
give a comma and I want my start name as
1 close the bracket hit enter it has
written me seven you can count it here
on the top so where the cursor is is the
first position so now keep shifting two
three four five
cell e52 that has Angela's defense
close the bracket hit enter it has
returned me 11.
so basically it has returned me this s
but since search function is case
insensitive so it did not care if it was
an uppercase s or a lowercase s
similarly if I want to find where a is
located or capital A is located in
Antonio minor
I'll use the search function
I want to find Capital a within text
I'll give
cell a54
now let's say I want to give my starting
num as 5.
close the bracket
it has written me 19
so it has written me this a
because the only a that exists after 5
is this
so here also since we searched for
Capital a but it looked for any a that
was present in Antonio Mino bit small or
capital
finally we have a clean function
so the clean function returns all
non-printable characters from the text
now you can see here this cell has three
lines of text now if you want to print
this cell in one line I can use the
clean function
it will remove all the non-printable
characters I'll select cell a67 close
the bracket hit enter there you go it
has printed the address in one line now
we have one more text which says I hope
you are doing well during the pandemic
now if I want to clean that cell
close the bracket it has printed the
same sentence in one line now there are
a few more functions let's see them one
by one we have a function called upper
so the upper function converts any text
string into upper case
so we have a string called India now if
I want to convert India into upper case
I'll use the upper function select that
cell you can see it here it has
converted India into uppercase
characters
similarly you can use the lower function
to convert any text string into
lowercase
I'll use the lower function
select that string enter
there you go
so all the letters in the word India has
been converted into lower case now there
is another function called proper which
is used to convert any string into
proper case
so I can write a vlooker function
something like this I'll give equal to
search for vlookup
now my lookup value will be stored
to comma
then I'll select my table array so I'll
take my table array from A2 to
C7
if you want you can choose the entire
table also
give a comma my column index number is
this department column which is the
third column
and range lookup is either true or false
I'll select false which is 0 for exact
match
if I hit enter you can see it has
returned marketing
and in the table also if you see Stuart
is from the marketing department so this
is a simple example how you can use
vlookup
now if you want you can choose the
entire table so I can select from A2
to E7 hit enter it will give the same
result now suppose I want to find from
the marketing department
so this is the person who is from the
marketing department I want to find the
city I'll use the vlooker function again
vlookup
now my lookup value is marketing
event column is the leftmost lookup
column
select the remaining table leave a comma
and my column index number is 2.
is the city column
and I'll give my range look up as 0
because I want the exact match I'll hit
enter you can see it has returned me the
city to which
this person from the marketing
department belongs to that is cancels
let's see another example
suppose I want to find the city to wish
the person with the last name Davis
belongs to so I'll write my vlookup
function I'll take my lookup value as
Davis give a comma now my table array
will start from the last name column
and let's select the remaining columns
as well
now my column index number is will be 3
as per our selection
for example let's say we want to find
the first name of the person who is from
Los Angeles city so we have our lookup
values Los Angeles and now we want to
find the first name so I'll again use
the lookup function I'll give my lookup
value as Los Angeles
comma Now my lookup Vector is the city
column comma a resultant Vector is the
first name column
close the bracket hit enter
you can see it has returned me Steward
which is actually wrong
you see our original table the person
who is from Los Angeles city is not
Steward but it's Lucy
so the mistake that we did was before
applying the formula we did not sort a
lookup column so let me short this
column in ascending order go to the data
tab I'll sort it I'll click sort now you
can see it has written Me Lucy and you
can see there was an error because we
sorted the table so the values changed
so be aware of this now let's try
another example let's say I want to find
the department of the person who was
hired on this particular date which is
10th of November 2001 so I can use the
lookup function here better hostile sort
this date hide column in ascending order
click on sort now let's find the
department of the person with the last
name as Davis
so you can see
Davis and the department it belongs to
is sales
so I'll use the edge lookup function
again select my lookup value as Davis
and give a comma Now my table array
I'll select from G2 to M5 now in this
selection my row index number will be 2
which is the department column
give a 0 close the bracket hit enter
it has returned sales so Davis is from
sales department moving ahead now
let's explore the IF function so the IF
function in Excel checks whether a
condition is satisfied or met
it returns a value if true else it will
return another value of the condition is
not satisfied so let me use
an IF function here
I'll give my logical test as
say the value in cell 11
if it's greater than 5 then I'll return
Yes 10 is greater else I'll return no
close the bracket hit enter
you can see the result
it says yes 10 is greater because our
condition 10 is greater than 5.
now if I change this value to 4
it returns no because 4 is not greater
than 5. now we have a question here
I want to add values to this result
column
so our condition is
if the player scores more than 50 and
average is more than 42 then he is a
good player else he's not a good player
so will return not so good so we have
three player names the runs they have
scored and the average they have so I'll
use the and give my condition
I'll write equal to if
now since I am checking for two
conditions that is the player should
score more than 50 and the average
should be more than 42 so I'll use and
and close here
so I'll check
if
p 22 which has the runs is greater than
and Q 22 is greater than 42 then we'll
return is a
good player
else
not so good close the bracket now if I
hit enter
it has returned me good player because
both runs and averages the meter
condition
now let me copy paste this formula
for this cell you can see Michael has
scored 40 runs and his average is also
40. is not so good because
our condition was we should have scored
more than 50 and average should be more
than 42 so both the conditions was not
met the next function we have is if n a
now the if any function will return the
value you specify if the expression
resolves to any value otherwise it will
return the result of the expression so I
want to find
the department of Anthony now you can
see the first name column this no name
as Anthony let's see what happens if you
want to find the department of Anthony
so I'll write equal to if n a now in
value I'll use a vlookup function I'll
give my value as R12 which is Anthony
and I'll choose my column as
from O2 to S7
give a comma Now the department or the
column index number is 3 which is the
department column
I'll give 0
close the bracket
give another comma
now if the value results in n a
will return
such as value not found hit enter
you can see it here it has written me
value not found because
our vlookup function could not find any
lookup value as Anthony in the first
name column so it returned value not
found
similarly there is one more function
called if a returned value not found
called if error
so the if error function Returns the
error value if the expression is an
error otherwise it Returns the value of
the expression if there is no error so
these two cells you can see we have some
values 10 and 0 let's say I want to use
the F error function and
the value I'll give is say I want to
divide
u3
by
u4 so I'm dividing 10 by 0
now
if the result is an error we'll return
cannot divide close the bracket hit
enter you can see it has returned me
cannot divide because you cannot divide
a number by zero hence there was an
error so it returned this value now
let's say I want to divide let's say I
want to use the if error function again
and now I want to divide W3 which has
the value 10 by W4 which is the value 5
I'll give the value if error that is
cannot
divide
if I hit enter it returns me true
because 10 is divisible by 5 so divided
10 by 5 and the result was 2. similarly
let's say I want to find
the city to which again there is no
Anthony's try this out I'll use the
index function now the array I will give
us
from Z 2 to AC 7. comma myronum is 3 and
the column number I want is 2 close it
returns me Davis which is this one the
reason being we skipped the header
column our column was selected from this
cell so this is our first row second row
third row so third row and second column
we have Davis similarly let's check for
fifth row and fourth column I'll use the
index function I'll give my array from
Z2 to 87 this time I'm selecting the
entire table
I'll give my row number as 5 and my
column as 4 close the bracket
hit enter
the result it returns is Boston you can
see
the fifth row is this one and the fourth
column is City so it underst Boston now
the match function
Returns the relative position of an item
in an array that matches a specified
value so if you want to find
the position at which
events is located in the table so you
can use the match function something
like this match I'll take my lookup
value as
y 15 which has events comma
now my lookup array
will be
the last name column because events was
from the last name column comma I'll
give 0 for exact match I'll hit enter it
gives me 5. events was present in the
fifth row let's check for Boston now
I'll use the match function again my
lookup value will be Boston comma my
lookup array will be the city column
comma I want the exact match close the
bracket hit enter
it returns 6. so if you start from the
beginning here this is the first row
second third fourth fifth and sixth in
sixth row we have Boston now you can use
this index match function to return a
value in a column to the left with
vlookup you are stuck returning a value
from a call I'll select my lookup array
from
Z1 to z7
comma 0
I close the brackets hit enter
it has written cancels you can see
Jensen the first name Jensen belong to
City Kansas similarly
let's find the city to wish the person
with the last name as events belongs to
so evens you can see from the table
belongs to Los Angeles let's find out
using our index match function
I'll write index
and then
array I'll give as
ec1 to ec7 comma
myronum
I'll give my match function
lookup value will be evens which is ab15
comma
look up array is ee12a7
which is our last name column and 0.
if I hit enter you can see it has
returned
Los Angeles
now let's find out the department to
which zampa belongs to
so I'll use my index function
now I'll select
my array from
aa1
to ac7
comma
I'll find the row number using the match
function
so my lookup value will be zampa which
is ab18
comma
the lookup array will be
A1 to a 7 comma 0
close the bracket
give one more comma now I'll find the
column number I'll again use
my match function to do it so this time
I want to find the location of
department so I'll give
Department that is eb1 as the reference
comma the lookup array will be from E1
to ed1 which are the column headers
comma 0
and I'll close the brackets if I hit
enter it gives me sales so you can see
here from the table xamper is from the
sales department
so in this way you can use index match
function to find the row number the
column number and the value you are
looking for now we'll talk about countif
countifs some apps and average functions
so you can see I am here in a new tab
now to check these functions I'm using a
coronavirus data set you can see it here
it has a date column then we have
divided the date into day month year
number of cases deaths countries from
which these cases and deaths came from
we have the continent and few other
information
so first let's see
what county function does so the county
function counts the number of cells
within a range that meet the given
condition
so we'll see these functions by taking
an example
so we have a question here we want to
count the number of times Afghanistan is
present in the data set so I'll consider
my G column that is countries and
territories
so I'll write my countif function I'll
give my range from G1 to the end of this
G column
I'll give a comma
go to the top now my criteria will be
Afghanistan
if you want you can use cell reference
as well I am typing the country name
manually if I hit enter it gives me 446
so in this column that is the G column
Afghanistan is present 146 times
similarly let's count the number of
times India is present in the data set
so I'll use the county function again
I'll select the same range you give a
comma Now my criteria will be India you
can see here India is present 155 times
moving on the next function will talk
about is countifs so the tips function
counts the number of cells specified in
a given set of conditions or criteria so
our question is count the total number
of days in which the cases in India have
been greater than 100 so to do this
count ifs function
I'll select
my criteria range
first I'll select the D column comma
my first criteria is we want to check
for India
and then
my second condition is that the number
of cases has to be greater than 100 so
my next criteria range will be the cases
column comma
and my condition is
greater than 100 close the bracket hit
enter the result is 68 so a total of 68
days India had
more than 100 cases the next example is
we need to count the number of days in
which the deaths in United States have
been greater than 200 so for that
I'll use the count ifs function I'll
give my criteria so this time I am
taking my first criteria as the case is
comma so the cases have to be greater
than 200
close the bracket hit enter
so you can see the total cases in India
till
3rd of June have been
more than 2 lakhs now I want to find the
total debts in the United States till
the 3rd of June I'll use the same
sumif function
now my first criteria will be the G
column
comma
I'll give my second value as
United States of America I'll use the
same format using underscore
States of
America
comma
now the second range will be the deaths
column
close the bracket hit enter you can see
the total deaths in the United States
till 3rd of June have crossed
one lakh similarly let's now
see our sumifs function so the sumits
function adds the cells specified in a
given set of conditions or criteria so
we have a question here we want to find
the total cases in France on those days
where the deaths have been less than 100
so this should be those days instead of
whose okay so let's see our sum UPS
function now
first we need to give the sum range
since we want to find the total cases so
we'll give the sum range as the column e
comma Now the second criteria is the
countries column so I'll give the G
column and we want to check for France
give that criteria comma the second
criteria is I need to find only for
those days where the debts have been
less than 100. so I'll give the deaths
column comma the criteria should be less
than 100.
close the bracket hit enter
is the result so the total cases in
France on those days where the debts
have been less than 100 is 20
638 now let's talk about the average
function so the average function finds
the average or the arithmetic mean of
the cells specified by a given condition
or criteria so our question is you want
to find the total average daily cases in
India this is till the 3rd of June so
I'll use the average function and my
first criteria I'll select is the
countries column and my criteria will be
India and then I'll give the range that
is the E column which has the cases if I
hit enter
so these are the daily average cases in
India till the 3rd of June next let's
talk about some date and time functions
in Excel you can see here I am in my
date and time sheet
so let's start with the today function
the today function Returns the current
date
or today's date
so if I write equal to
today close the bracket hit enter it
will return me today's date which is
28th of July now you can use the Now
function which will return the current
date and time value
so if I write equal to now
if I hit enter
you can see it has returned the current
date and the time so this is basically
the system date and time you can see it
here now there is another function
called time the time function converts
hours minutes seconds given as numbers
to an Excel serial number formatted with
a time format so you can see here I'll
write the time function now let's see
I'll give my RS as 20 so it's in 24
hours format let's say minute I'll give
40 and seconds I'll give 20 we close the
bracket hit enter the time is 8 40 PM
you can subtract the Now function from
today function to return the time value
so let me show it to you here I'll write
my Now function and I'll subtract today
so hit enter
it returns me the time this is the
system time now
there's another function in Excel called
Date diff function which Returns the
difference between two dates in terms of
years months and days
now here I have a date of birth which is
30 December 1994
and we have today's date I have used the
2D function
if I want to find the age I can use the
date D function so I'll write date div
and in that I'll give my
first date value as the date of birth
which is 30 December 1994
comma my second date value will be
today's date which is 28th of July
now I want to find the age in terms of
years so within double course I'll give
y right enter it gives me 25 so it has
subtracted our first state value and the
second date value to return the year now
the date D function will always return a
whole number you can see it here this
was a whole number you can use the ear
Frac function in Excel to return the
year fraction representing the number of
whole days between the start date and
the end date so I can use the ear Frac
function here
write your Frac my start date will be
ready to birth
now the end date will be today's day
comma basis
I'll give one which is actually it will
divide the actual number of days by the
actual days in a year right enter
it gives me my ear fraction which is 25
point
now let's see
I'll replace one with let's say 2. write
enter it gives me
25.95 you can see it here if you give
two it will divide the actual disk by
360. Now the default value is 0. moving
ahead we have the weekday function
now the weekday function returns a
number from 1 to 7 identifying the day
of the week of a date so
let me use the weekday function I'll
give my
serial number as today right enter it
gives me three now let's say I want to
use the weekday function again I'll
use
my cell reference E2 which has the
today's date comma
now the return type
I'll give as 2
which means
it starts from Monday through Sunday so
the first day of the week starts on a
Monday and ends on a Sunday tip 2 close
the bracket hit enter it gives me two
the second day of the week then we can
have your day function month function
and your function let's explore them one
by one so the day function Returns the
day of the month it will have a number
between 1 to 31
so 1 means the beginning of the month
and 31 means the last day of the month
so if I use my day function on
E2 which is today's date
if I hit enter
it gives me 28 that is 28th of July
similarly let's check for month
I'll give the same cell reference hit
enter it gives me 7 which means the July
month
now let's find the year give the cell
reference hit enter
it returns me the year that is 2020. now
you can extract the hours minutes and
seconds from a Time Value so I'll use
the r function to get the r value from
the current time you can see it has
returned 14 which means it's 2 pm now
let's find out the minute also I'll use
the minute function give my Now function
hit enter
19 so it's 2 pm and 19 minutes now let's
find out the seconds also I'll give my
Now function to get the second also
there's another function in Excel called
days 360. so days 360 function Returns
the number of days between two dates
based on a 360 day year
so we assume that in a year all the
months have 30 days so I'll use my
days 360 function
I'll give my start date as my date of
birth which is B12
comma the end date
I'll give today's date which is in B 13
and the method I'll use is true which is
European method
you can see what the European method
says
the start dates and end dates that occur
on the 31st day of a month will be equal
to the 30th day of that month
close the bracket hit enter it gives me
the total number of days that were
between
my first date that is the starting date
and the end date similarly now let's use
these 360 once again
I'll give my start date let's say 25th
of June 2020 and my end date will be
today's date so get the total number of
days that is 33. similarly we have your
month which means end of month so end of
month function Returns the serial number
of the last day of the month before or
after a specified number of months so
I'll use my EO month I'll give my start
date as B12 which is my date of birth
and then I want the number of months to
be 10 hit enter you can see it has given
us the next day when the month is ending
so it is 31st of October 1995. coming to
Vietnam function the week num function
Returns the week number of the year so
I'll use my week num function and my
serial number will be today's date comma
the return type I want is 2 so I want my
beat to begin on a Monday so I'll give
two close the bracket hit enter
it gives me 31 so
today's date that is 28th of July is the
31st week of the year let's explore a
few more functions
we have Network days and work days now
these are Advanced functions
of date and time in Excel
now the network days function Returns
the number of whole working days between
two dates
so Network days automatically excludes
weekends that is Saturday and Sunday and
can optionally exclude a list of
holidays supplied as dates now I have
listed down the list of holidays this is
from the U.S calendar
and the list of holidays are for the
current year that is 2020
so first let's use our Network this
function to find the number of working
days between two date values
so I'll write
Network days
and let's say I'll give my first date or
the starting date as
first of July
and I'll give my second date value
as 31st of
July
2020 close the bracket hit enter it
gives me 23. now let me show you the
calendar now this is the July calendar
if you can see
the first day of July starts on
Wednesday
and it ends on Friday and in between we
have one two three four five six seven
and eight so total we have eight
weekends
so our Nets skipped counting these
weekends so since July is at 31 days
month it has subtracted those eight days
those were on weekends so 31 minus 8 is
23 so in total we have 23 working days
in July now let's say I want to include
the holiday calendar also so I'll use
the network days function Again YouTube
My starting the workday function returns
serial number of the date before or
after a specified number of work days
the Excel workday function takes date
and Returns the nearest working day in
the future or past it can be used in
logistics to calculate shipping dates
delivery dates that need to take into
account working and non-working days it
automatically excludes weekends that is
Saturdays and Sundays so let me use my
work day function I'll give my start
date as
first of July
and the number of days I'll give us five
close the bracket hit enter
it has written me a serial number you
can convert this into a date value so
our next working date after first of
July is 8th of July if you see the
calendar we started on 1st of July so
counting five days after first of July
so one two three
4 and 5 so the next working day after
five days will be 8th of July so it has
kept counting the weekends
4th of July and 5th of July similarly
I'll use the workday function again this
time I'll give my starting date
as first of July only and now
I want to find the next working days
after five days and I'll give my holiday
list close the bracket hit enter I can
convert this into a date value you can
see it has given us 9th of July because
five days we had a holiday that is 3rd
of July which was an Independence Day
finally let's move on to our next and
the final section in this tutorial for
functions and formulas we have some
Financial functions so these Financial
functions are commonly used in Banking
and Financial sectors let's have a look
at them one by one first we have the PMT
function now the Excel PMT function is a
financial function that Returns the
periodic payment for a loan the PMT
function can be used to figure out the
future payments for a loan assuming
constant payments and a constant
interest rate so I'll just show you the
arguments the PMT function takes you can
see it takes rate in PR or nper PV FP
and type so rate is the interest rate
for the loan and P ER is the total
number of payments for the loan PV is
the future value or the total value of
all loan payments now FV is the future
value or a cash balance you want after
the last payment is made by default is
zero type it is optional when premines
are due so 0 means end of period 1 means
beginning of period now let's use the
PMT function to find
the future payments for a loan so I have
my data here on the top I have my rate
as five percent I'll use
cell reference E2 comma
then I want my NPR or number of period
so I'll give myself B2
comma
the present value is my loan amount
that is 2 lakhs
comma
I don't want any future value it keep it
as 0
close the bracket hit enter
you can see it has returned us the PMT
amount or the principal amount
now you can see it has given us
a negative number the reason being the
amount is getting deducted from our
present value so to solve this issue you
can give
a negative sign here so if I copy paste
the formula again let me put it in this
cell
equal to I'll paste it
now if I
give a negative sign now I can edit this
instead of 4 I'll give 12 because we
want to find it monthly so
will convert our annual interest rate to
monthly interest rate now and I'll
multiply the NPR or the number of
periods into 12 and I'll hit enter
so this is a future value of the PMT
monthly moving on
if you have a table here you can see
there have been a series of cash flow
over a period of time
Now using this table I want to use my
irr and xirr function
so the irr function in Excel Returns the
internal rate
of a series of cash flows so if I want
to find the internal rate of return I'll
use the irr function
and
I'll select my values from
B16 to B21
close the bracket
so this is my irr value that is 22
percent
if I want to find the X error value I'll
use the X irr function that Returns the
internal rate for a schedule of cash
flows that occur in irregular intervals
now for using the X irr function I'll
use this table now you can see it has
irregular cash flows over a period of
time
so let me use my X irr function
I'll give my values ranging from
F 22
to
f27
comma the dates I'll give from e22 to
e27
close the bracket hit enter this is my x
irr value up next
we'll see how to find out the feature
value
so for using the future value use the FV
function in Excel that Returns the
future value of an investment you can
use the FV function to get the future
value of an investment assuming periodic
constant payments with a constant
interest rate also
so this is my table
so we have an annual interest rate of 10
percent yes we have eight Ann yearly
payment we have one lakh now to find the
future value I'll use equal to f v
rate I'll give G4
which is 10 percent comma
nper I'll give G5 which is the number of
years that is 8. and yearly payment I'll
give one lakh which is G6 comma
present value 0 type is also zero
right enter so this is my future value
which is 11 lakhs
43 588
similarly if you want to find the
present value so you can use the PV
function which Returns the present value
of an investment that is a total amount
that is series of future payments is
worth now
so let me use the PV function I'll give
my rate as eight percent which is G13
comma my number of periods is 5 or you
can assume 5 years
comma my PMT or payment per period is
10 000
comma future value 0 type is also zero
so this is my present value
up next we have the net present value or
the npv function
so the npv formula or the function
calculates the net present value of an
investment based on a discount rate and
a series of future payments having
negative values and income having
positive values so you can see in the
table here
our investment has a negative value
and our incomes have positive values and
we have a discount rate of 10 percent
now let's find the Net Present Value we
use the npv function now the rate I'll
give is 10 percent comma rules and we
could just say greater than that's an
easier way I could also go ahead and
create a new rule but then I can use one
of this option I can say greater than
and let's give some value might be we
would be interested in looking at any
value greater than 12 000 so let's
choose 12.
and here it says what color would you
want to select so for example I would
say something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay so right now what I'm
doing is
I have all the values where the revenue
generated was greater than 10 000 but
then I have also selected all the sales
people who have made or who have
generated Revenue greater than 12 000.
so I can just do a Ctrl Z to see the
previous result now here I had the
values which were greater than 10 000
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than twelve thousand so this is one
simple example now we can look at some
other examples say for example you want
to format cells using three color scale
so if you look at the values here I have
a three color scale mainly in green
yellow and red and how do you do this so
for example I can go in here and I can
go to conditional formatting so I would
want to go for color scales and here you
can create different rules so we can set
up a two color scale so we can say
format only values that are above and
below average I can format only cells
that contain something I can get the top
and bottom value so these are different
ways in which I can have a three color
based scale now what I will do is I will
select this and let me show you the rule
which I have so for example I can go
into manage rules and if you see here
there are certain rules which have been
specified now what does that mean so you
would want to specify a three grade
scale so for example if I would want to
look at my first rule it tells me that I
am choosing three color scale I can
choose lowest value percentile and
highest value and that basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is I can
basically
use one of these values I can delete
these rules which I have created so for
example I have all these rules but you
should always carefully remember that
the rules will be applied in the order
shown so for example if I just delete
these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now it does not have any
highlighting now I can go in here I can
say condition sorry conditional
formatting I could go for color scale so
I could basically go into
new rule so I would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red I can say midpoint
is percentile 50 and then the highest
value is green and if that looks good
let's say okay and now if you see the
lowest values have been highlighted as
red you have mid values and then you
have the positive value so this is the
three color scale and that easily helps
me in identifying the data based on the
cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can basically color
the cells based on their value so what
we are seeing here is if the revenue
generated is greater than average then
that shows in green and if the revenue
generated is lesser than average that's
shows in Orange now how do we do that so
we can basically again manage some rules
so I can basically create a new rule now
here I can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option I would want to select now I can
select this and it says format values
that are above average so in our case we
had it in green so for example I'll say
above average and then here I can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size so
let's go and look into
the formatting so for example let's
choose yellow
say okay now I'm saying wherever the
cell values are above average it would
be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here let's go and look
into manage rules so this is basically
the rule which we are applying now we
can also add a new rule
and I need to select the values so for
example I will say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below we'll go for format we will
choose red we'll say okay we'll say
now these are basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if I select this and then I
could basically choose my area just hit
on enter and similarly you can go in
here and then select your area hit on
enter and say apply say okay and now if
you see I have really chosen bright
colors but then I have said wherever my
revenue generated is above average it
should be in yellow and
below average should be in Red so we
wanted above
average to be in green and below average
to be in Orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also find the top 10
and bottom 10 values and that's pretty
easy so you can just select this and
then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items or
you can go in for more rules so you can
say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10 now you can
choose the color and for example I'll go
for blue
and I'll say okay so now if you see my
top 10 values are blue now similarly I
can add one more rule so I can say new
rule and I can say let's go for top or
bottom let's go for bottom let's go for
format let's say orange
say okay say okay and that's it so now
you have your values which are top or
bottom 10 values so you are using
conditional formatting where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors and here
easy conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing so what we can do is we can
select our columns either you could
apply this to all the columns now here I
have applied this only to Jan and April
now I could apply this for June so let's
say June so you can go for gradient fill
you can go for solid fill you can
obviously just select the color and that
takes care of the things you can say for
example select this and now this is
selected what I would want to might be
format this so I can go in here I can go
into manage rules now that will tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so I can just do a edit
Rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill which is color you have no
border this is basically color as black
now I can go for something like gradient
fill
and I can say okay and now if I say
apply and okay so this basically is Like
Your First Column so you can use
conditional formatting for various use
cases and you can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be here the revenue is getting
generated or was getting generated but
did not grow Beyond a particular value
and so on now similarly you can also go
in for different options say for example
here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased or say for
example if the revenue was going up for
this particular sales person so here we
are looking at Carol so in Jan the
revenue Generation by sales was very
high then in Feb it was falling down
in March it was kind of stable then in
April it went way below so we can
obviously work on this wherein we can
grade our cell values so what we can do
is we can go in for
highlighting the cell values now you can
go for color scales you can go for Icon
sets and this is where you can choose
your different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example I would be interested in
looking at the indicators like
directional I could go
using this three arrows I can go in for
this color I can choose directional and
then my values are
automatically using directional now what
we can also do is we can then go into
manage rules and that basically tells me
what rules have been applied so for
example the latest one is the icon set
which I have chosen it shows the
selected columns I can obviously do a
edit Rule and then I can choose so I'm
saying the format style is icon sets I'm
not using a data bar I'm not using color
scale now here I have chosen the style
of icons
and then here you can basically give
some values so you have icon which is
green when the value is greater than or
equal to 67 percentage
when I say hyphen or minus it is less
than 67. it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily highlight your
cell values based on this icon set so I
can apply this and that's how I use
conditional formatting so conditional
formatting can be very useful if you
would want to use icon set if you want
to use your data bars if you would want
to highlight particular values if you
would want to color code based on some
calculation if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts or people
who are working in business intelligence
teams or people who would want to use
Excel to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value or finding out less
significant or more significant cells to
then pull out values and carry out your
computations calculations or analysis
let's learn one more feature of Excel
and that's basically your data
validation now this can be very useful
when you would want to work on
validating the data which is being fed
in the cells so you could limit it to
basically a number between a particular
value you could also add some messages
to it if you would want or you could
even
Circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in Excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a Cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed now
that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict that the name should accept
only 15 characters now how do you do
that so you can basically select the
cells or you can just select a
particular cell and then we can later
drag the property to other fields now
here once the cell is selected so for
example let's try this out and let's see
if that works so for example example I
will say Peter Johnson
okay and that is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
Junior
and if I do this it says input length is
greater than 15 do you want to continue
if I say yes right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then it has basically violated the
rule now this is giving a message to the
user that the username should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that so for this we can basically select
the column and then we can search for
data Tab and get into Data validation so
this is where you can create or select
different kind of rules so for example I
can go into Data validation I can go
into settings and I can say the text
length and that should be less than 15
now this is the maximum I'm giving and
it says apply these changes to all other
cells within the same settings so I can
do this or I can just drag and drop so I
can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
Control Data validation in this
particular column and that will allow
only 15 characters it will pop up a
message if the user really wants to go
beyond the particular limit now you also
have similarly date of birth so the
Restriction is date of birth should be
between 10 Jan 1990 to 30 December 1998
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here I have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range that is 10 Jan date
1990 12 30 1998 so that's the start and
the end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up which says
enter a valid date now I can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so I can say stop I can say
invalid entered
and this is how I have set a rule so for
example if I just do something like this
and that says invalidate entered I can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until I did not give the
right format the date will not be
accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well I
would want to apply this rule to all
these rows starting from C2 to c14 so
let's get into Data validation let's
look in settings and here we are
choosing custom now within custom I am
choosing what is the formula so I'm
saying is number
and then I'm saying find
at the rate for
the rows C2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here is the value
should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for error
alert so for example we can basically go
in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title I'm giving and we can
say email should contain
at the rate so if I do this and if I say
ok now you can test it so you can say A
B C D and that says email should contain
at the rate and basically that will not
allow me to add the values so now you
have the field called salary it says
salary should be greater than fifty
thousand now we can limit the values by
choosing a whole number so for example
for salary I can go into Data validation
I can go into settings so here I can say
something like decimal or I can go for
whole number so both of the things are
fine it depends on what kind of values
get into this particular field so if I
say whole number and if I say it has to
be greater than 50 000 so I'm saying the
minimum is 50 000 or I could have given
a decimal and then I can say greater
than less than equal or anything or even
between so I can select greater than and
then I can just say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will generally
not be decimal so this would be whole
number salary is can be a whole number
or it could be decimals so we have
chosen decimal here and in rank if you
click on data validation I have chosen
whole number
I have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends I can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be based on a list of items
now for example here if you see I have
two columns so one column basically has
the values of city names and then you
have places within that particular City
so if I would want to implement a data
validation based on this so for example
if you see here City and that basically
shows me only the four values which can
be entered and if I go to place then it
tells me for Maharashtra I can only
enter Pune Mumbai nashik now how do I do
this so say for example you take an
empty field and you want to restrict the
values of city names so I could select
data validation I could basically select
list and then it tells me you need to
enter the list values that is the source
so you click here and then I can just
select these fields now if I do this and
if I say OK it has implemented a data
validation but if you look into this it
will show me the same thing but then it
shows me some empty cells which did not
have any value so this is fine but it
would be better if we do it in a
different way so I can select this and I
have already given my city names here so
I can just do a data validation and here
in the source let me get rid of this now
I can just have my cursor here I can
select these values and then if I say ok
so now if you see my city names have
been restricted to these values and
that's how you can Implement your data
validation so I have this data
validation here but I will get rid of
this one by just doing a control Z now
I'll come here and say for example I
would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
in doing this for all my four cities now
if you see here I have data validation I
could choose Bangalore and if you come
and check here there is no data
validation but we have implemented data
validation here now how is that done so
I could select this or for example I can
go in here I can select data validation
I can select list and then here in the
source I will say for Bangalore the
value should be these and then if I
basically say okay
now if we see these are the values which
are fed into Bangalore so we could do
this or like what we have done here so
if you can check the data validation
rule I have used list and then I have
said indirect F2 so basically I'm giving
in a formula which relates to the value
which is in for the city Maharashtra so
we could do this or in a simpler way we
could do this and then just drag and
drop here so we could check for
Maharashtra what are the values let's
choose a different city so for example
Kolkata and here I will choose now since
we did a drag and drop it has basically
taken the values of Bangalore so that's
not right so we select this we go into
Data validation and here I can either
feed in the values that is such as
Bangalore I could basically say
something like this Kolkata and I could
say okay so now if you see it shows me
the places in Kolkata now here we have
let's choose a different city so for
example let's go for Delhi and here I
can go to data validation and I can just
say Delhi so this is an easier way of
doing it or if you remember the formula
then what you can do is you can just
give in
indirect and then basically
give the value of the cell for which you
would want to
keep in the values so this is how you
can do list validation so you can
provide a list of values and then you
can restrict the values in a Cell which
should be belonging to a particular list
so this is how you do a simple data
validation by restricting the data in
the form of a list
Excel is a really powerful tool for data
analytics and Reporting and pivot tables
are one of the features that Excel
offers for creating tabular reports to
summarize our data
let's begin by understanding what is a
pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in its spreadsheet to
obtain a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables are specially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now
let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table
similar to The Columns all row labels
are unique values and duplicates are
removed
columns
is the second component
when a field is chosen for the column
area only the unique values of the field
are listed across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displace the
summarized information the most common
values are sum average minimum and
maximum finally we have filters filters
apply a calculation or restriction to
the entire table
so let's jump over to Microsoft Excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo so with India
being ready for its 16 census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze India's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across India stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socioeconomic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in Excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first I'll show you one of the features
that Excel offers us so suppose I click
on any cell and hit Control Plus Q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis
now you can see by default Excel has
prompted certain features such as
formatting we have charts totals and
this one more called tables now Excel by
default has created some pivot tables
for us now the first one you say is sum
of district code by state names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have some of child sex ratio
some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others before creating our pivot
table so let's have a final look at our
data set
so First Column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of India then we
have the state code we have the state
name district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each City
then we have the male and female
literates next we have the sex ratio sex
ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population for each of the states
in descending order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell
in your data go to the insert Tab and
here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivotal so let me select pivot
table
now my range is already selected the
entire table
and here I'll choose existing worksheet
because I want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet
and I'll give my location I'll point to
cell Q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table Fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state so what I'll
do is
I'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different state names listed
now
we want the total population for each of
these states
so in the field list I'll search for
total population which is this one and
drag it under values
you can see
we have a sum of total population for
each of these states by default
Excel will sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want now we want to
sort this column in descending order so
I right click go to sort option and
choose Z to A that is largest to
smallest
you can see here in 2011 Maharashtra had
the highest number of population
or the total population in Maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
Pradesh we had Andhra Pradesh
and if I come down we have nagaland and
Andaman and nicobar Islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created now the next problem we have is
we want to find the total sum of
literacy belonging to a certain state so
let's see how to do it
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
here I can click on pivot table
my range is selected I'll choose
existing worksheet and give my location
which is Q5
I click on OK
now here we want to find the total sum
of literates so what I'll do is first
let me drag
total literates column two values you
have the total sum of literates from all
the states
next I want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag state name onto rows
and then
will drag City
on two rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
you can see we have the state names and
the cities per state and on the right
you can see the total number of
literates from each City if I scroll
down we have Assam then you can see we
have Bihar
and if I keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana Himachal Pradesh this
German Kashmir which has now become a
union territory
as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in 2011.
so let's create a pivot table for this
I'll click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing I'll select cell Q5
and click on OK
now since we want the average sex ratio
and the child sex ratio so first I'll
drag those columns either you can
manually scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it so if I look for child
okay we have
the same
column listed you can just drag it from
there let me delete this
and I also want the sex ratio
so I'll place it on top of child sex
ratio
next we want to see it based on
different states so what I'll do is
I'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have a on the
left you can see we have the different
state name slip you can see we have our
column sorted now
so in 2011 Kerala had the highest sex
ratio
and if I scroll down to the bottom you
can see himanchal Pradesh at the lowest
which is around 818.
up next let's explore one more feature
of pivot table so suppose you want to
see the top or bottom few rows of a
pivot table you can do that as well so
here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates so let's see from the entire
pivot table how we can filter the top
three cities
so I'll go to insert
click on the pivot table option
go to existing worksheet click on Q5
and hit OK
now since we want to find the top three
cities I'll drag
City column onto rows and then
we want the female graduates so in the
search bar I'll look for female
and I'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values
so I have
the sum of female graduates for each of
the Cities now since we want to find the
highest in the top three cities so let
me first short this column
I'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted now from this you
can see that Delhi greater Mumbai and
Bengaluru are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
Click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 I'll select this
here I only want the top three so either
you can
Goods or you can directly
type 3
your column is already selected let me
just click on OK
there you go we have the required Vivo
table ready and it only displays us the
top three cities with the highest number
of female graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a Slicer in a pivot table so we
have a question here What's the total
population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the table
click on existing I'll click on a
location this time q6
click ok
now since I want the total population so
I'll drag total population onto values
and then
I'll select
the city
onto rows and then the state name also
As Cities
but our question is we want to find only
for Rajasthan and Karnataka
now for that what you can do is
go to insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer and click on this
and since we want to slice the table
based on
state that is Rajasthan and Karnataka
I'll choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for Rajasthan and Karnataka so
I'll search for
these two so here we have Karnataka so
let me select Karnataka first
and I also want for Rajasthan
so let me select Rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have
data for Rajasthan and Karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
Karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for Rajasthan
moving ahead now we will see another
very interesting feature of pivot that
is how you can
create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that
I'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and I'll select an empty cell
okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates so first I'll drag
male literatures onto values
followed by female literatures onto
values by default it has summed up the
mean literacy and female literates value
and also I want to drag
State column
to rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
I want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is
I'll select any cell
and
I'll right click
and I'll go to so value as and here I
have the option to select percentage of
grand total so I'll select this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total
now if I sort this you will get to know
which state contributed or has the
highest percentage contribution
so we have Maharashtra for male
literatures
then we had uttar Pradesh in 2011
if I come down
we had meghalaya nagaland and Andaman
and nicobar Islands
as two states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
I'll go to show value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also Maharashtra
uttar Pradesh then Gujarat and all had
the
highest percentage contribution to
female literatures
so this is another good feature
to convert your data and see time in
terms of percentage
now moving ahead let's say we want to
find the bottom three cities from each
state that had the lowest female
graduates
we can do that as well I'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on OK
now since I want to see based on States
as well as cities so let me drag the
state name first onto rows
and let's drag the city column onto rows
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
I'll drag it onto values
now we have the list of states and their
respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each City
now
first I'll
sort this column
I'll right click go to sort and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from
shortest or smallest to largest now
since I want to find the bottom three
cities from each state I'll come to the
cell
right click go to filter and select top
10.
now I'll
replace top 10 with bottom and I want
the bottom three cities from each state
I have my
column selected that is sum of female
graduates if I click on OK
you can see here some of the states
don't have three cities so you can see
Andaman and Uber islands has only one
city that is Port Blair while the
remaining you can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so Andhra
Pradesh had these three in Assam we had
nagao then there was dibrugar and
silchar
similarly if I come down in haryana we
have palwal kathal and zind
if I come further here you can see for
Karnataka this kangavati this Rani
benoor and this Kolar similar you can
see for Kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example I'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in Excel with the
help of a pivot table
so in a pivot table you can create or
use custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items calculated fields or
formulas that can refer to other fields
in the pivot table
calculated Fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value Fields a calculated Fields
name May proceed with sum of followed by
the field name
so here we have a sales table that has
columns like the items which has
different fruits and vegetables and
those have been categorized as fruits
and vegetables we have the price per kg
and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
sales for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field
so your sales column is going to be the
product of price per kg and quantity so
let me show you how you can do that with
the help of a pivot table
I'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit OK
now
if you see on the top under pivot table
analyze
and under calculations we have the
option Fields items and sets if I click
on this drop down I get the option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field I click on this
I'll give my field name as sales
and I'll select my formula
I'll first click on price per kg and hit
insert field
I'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol and then I'll double
click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
I'll click on ADD
and I click on OK
if you see here
there is a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is seals but it did not add it to our
original table or original table is the
same but here we have added a calculated
field which is present only in the pivot
table list now we can use this it has
already taken it under values now let's
say I want to find the sum of sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here we have our category
fruit and we have our category vegetable
and under that we have different items
like apple apricot banana similarly in
vegetables we have broccoli this carrots
corn eggplant and others
so this is how you can create a
calculated field in a pivot table
now there's one more good feature that
Excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart so you can use your
pivot table and create different charts
so I'll show you how to do that
if I go to insert
here I have the option of recommended
charts if I click on this Excel gives me
some default charts which you can use
let's say I'll select this
let me drag it a bit to the right
here you can see I'll close this pivot
field list
this is a nice bar chart that Excel has
created this is called a pivot chart now
here you can see the category fruits and
vegetables and the different fruits and
vegetables or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
seals if you see from the graph guava
made the highest amount of sales now if
I sort this let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava meet the
highest amount of sales now since I
sorted and changed my pivot table the
pivot chart also automatically gets
updated similarly there are other charts
also that you can create let's go to the
insert Tab and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on OK
so here is our pie chart and each Pi
represents a certain item
and the pi that has the highest area
represents
it had the highest amount of sales in
this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and others
let's explore a few other charts so
first I'll
click on my pivot table go to insert and
under recommended charts let's now
select a line chart
if I hit OK
move it to the right so this is a line
chart
you can see it starts
from guava
which had the highest amount of sales
then it drops
and in the x axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables broccoli made the
highest amount of sales with
2800 rupees and our lowest was eggplant
at 900 rupees for fruits papaya sold the
least at 700 rupees
let's take another chart I'll go to
insert
under recommended charts let's see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this
is an horizontal bar chart now you can
always increase and decrease the size of
this charts
let's explore
our last start let's take the area chart
for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the line chart it starts with
guava which had the highest amount of
sales similarly papaya under fruits had
the lowest amount of seals and the
vegetables it was
broccoli and finally eggplant made the
lowest amount of sales under vegetable
now let's go to our first seed and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for people tables in Excel so we had our
data
this is a 2011 Census Data from India we
had the different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literates female literates male
literature we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding how to
create a simple pivot table where we
calculated the total population for each
state and sorted it in descending order
we found that Maharashtra uttar Pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then we saw
another preview table where we
calculated the total sum of literates in
each City belonging to a certain state
so you can see we had the different
state names and the cities under each
state
then
we saw another feature where you could
calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that Delhi
greater Mumbai and Bengaluru were the
top cities with highest number of female
graduates next we saw how to use Slicer
in a pivot table so we sliced our table
based on Rajasthan Karnataka State and
saw the total population for all the
cities in Rajasthan and Karnataka
in the next sheet
we explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literatures from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates one thing
marked that some of the states did not
have three cities for example Andaman
had only one city that was sport player
but the others we found out the bottom
three cities that had the lowest female
graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table so we
saw
how to create a calculated field called
sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw
there's a column chart we also saw or
looked at
a bar chart that was a horizontal bar
chart similarly we saw how to create a
pie chart as well
in this video we will learn some of the
important features and functionalities
of power Query in Excel also we'll be
doing an extensive Hands-On
demonstration using various data sets
so if you want the data sets and the
demo files then please put your email
IDs in the comment section of the video
I'll team will send you the files over
email let's begin
so what is Excel power query
power query is an advanced feature of
Microsoft Excel that allows you to
prepare your data for analysis you can
perform numerous text computations and
numerical analysis to make your data
more powerful and informative Excel
power query is a data preparation and
transformation engine
it allows you to carry out the extract
transform and load operations on the
data sets from multiple sources
now
let's look at the challenges solved by
power query
earlier in Excel there was difficulty in
data connections Now using power query
you can connect to a broad range of data
sources such as relational databases web
files text CSV Json files and even fetch
data in the cloud volume variety and
velocity are the characteristics that
define Big Data it was a major problem
to handle such data Now power query
enables you to transform your data to an
appropriate size it also allows you to
work on any sheep of data from any
source
earlier updating your data and
refreshing it in real time was an issue
using power query reputable process
query is adopted to update the data in
real time and in the future
in Excel it was not so easy to reshape
transform and manipulate data but using
power query provides a highly
interactive experience and sophisticated
tools to prepare your data now
from Excel 2016 onwards power query on
Windows has been fully integrated into
Excel but in Excel 2010 and 2013 for
windows power query is a free add-in
you can go ahead and download the link
once installed the power query tab will
be visible in the Excel ribbon now
coming to the features of power query so
Excel power query allows you to clean
transform manipulate and process your
data for analysis it helps you to
automate repetitive tasks that you want
to do it over and over again you can
search for data sources and make
connections as and when you want Power
query helps you to prepare and shape the
data in the right format for performing
analysis
and finally once your data is ready you
can share your findings or use your
query to create interactive reports and
dashboards
now let's have a glance at the demo that
we are going to work on in this video
so we look at how to load data from
different sources
you will understand how to extract
tables from web files so we'll extract
tables present on Wikipedia Pages then
you'll learn how to sort and filter data
up next you'll see how to group your
data how to split a column into multiple
columns
and then pivot and unpivot your table
then date columns and make some
transformations
understand how to append tables and
merge tables vertically and horizontally
now let's open MS Excel and start with
importing a simple text file so you can
see here I have my Excel file opened and
in the middle you can see I have my
employee txt file
now this is a comma separated file
meaning that the values are separated by
commas as you can see it here
The Columns have been separated by
commas and all the values have a comma
between them
now this text file has information about
the name age company and the city to
which the employee belongs to
let's see how easily you can import this
EMP text file into Ms Excel here I am
using
Excel 365 or Office 365 where power
query on Windows has been fully
integrated into this version of excel
so what I'll do is first
let's go to the data Tab and
you have this section called get and
transform data so I'll click on get data
under get data I'll go to from file
and select from Text slash CSV
once I click on it it will ask me to
give the location where the file is
there so my file is on desktop I'll
click on power query files and here you
can see I have my employee txt file you
can see the type here it says text
document
click on EMP
and hit import
now this will take some time to import
the file onto Excel
it's a stab areas and connections so we
have made one query and have loaded
the employee data
it gives a preview also you can see it
here
and if needed later you can go to edit
and change some values that we'll see
later
now you can use this data to create
simple visualizations so let me show you
how to do it so let's first select the
data and we'll go to the insert tab
under insert tab I'll click on
recommended charts
let's see
I want to know how many employees belong
to a particular City
so I'll click on the second chart which
says the count of Name by City And I'll
click on OK
here you can see
we have a nice clustered bar chart and
you can see in Bangalore there were five
employees in Hyderabad we had two and in
nashik we had one you can see the count
here this is a pivot table
if we go back to our actual data here
you can see
in Bangalore we had Vidya Sonam Avinash
Varun and himani
and there were
two more people from Hyderabad and one
from nasik
so you can use the Excel power query
feature to import data onto Excel and
make some visualizations
now if you want to fetch some data that
is present on the web or on the Internet
Excel power query features and
functionalities can help you import
those data as well
we will now see how to import data
specifically a table that is present on
the web
here I'll be using a Wikipedia article
on the list of European Cup and UEFA
Champions League finals let me show you
the page first
so this is my Wikipedia page on the list
of European Cup and UFO Champions League
finals if I scroll down you can see all
the details here
and I would like to import this table
which has the list of all the finals so
we have columns like season winners
score Line run us up venue and
attendance let's import this table on to
excel
so I'll copy this URL first
now let me open a new sheet I'll go to
sheet1
and then on the data tab
under the get data section
I'll go to from other sources and here I
have from web which allows me to import
data from the web either you can follow
this path or if you see here there's an
option to get data from the web if I
click on this
it is asking me to enter the URL so I'll
paste the URL of the Wikipedia page here
and let's click on OK
now it's navigating and okay
you can see
power query feature in Excel has given
us a list of tables which you can see
here
we have something called as document
there's a key table and here you can see
there's one table which was extracted
from the Wikipedia page
and the table which I am interested in
is this table which has the list of
European Cup
finals
you can see it here
Excel power query feature has
automatically detected these rows and it
has given a
list of columns as well you can see
these are the columns
now we'll explore the transform data tab
present in the per query
now if I click on transform data it will
take me to the power query editor
let me just click on refresh now this is
the most important section
using the power query editor you can
clean your data filter your data
manipulate your data
and make it ready for analysis
now let's explore a few tabs available
here so we have a Home tab that has
a query section you can see you can
reduce rows manage columns sort the data
transform the data combine different
tables
now there is another tab called
transform which allows you to select
your data type transpose your rows and
columns
pivot and unpivot your columns and here
you can see you can find out some
summary statistics
and you can manage your date values as
well
now if you want to add some new columns
to your data you can do that as well and
you also have a view tab
now here
if you see the first two rows the values
are the same you can see season season
these are all repeated which we actually
don't need
and these are pretty similar to our
column names
similarly if I scroll down
you see there are some rows
which have null values
so actually these rows do not add up any
value or do not add any value to our
data so we'll clean this data first
so let's see how to do it
now if you want to remove certain rows
in the table what you can do is
go to the Home tab and under reduce rows
click on remove rows
and then choose remove top rows
if I select remove top rows it will ask
me how many rows do you want to remove
from the top
you can see it here I'll give I want to
remove the top two rows
now let's click on OK
you will see
that the Excel power query editor has
removed the first two rows and on the
right you can see the steps that were
applied
you can see it here previously we had
these two rows which were redundant and
once we applied the step
it has removed the first two rows
similarly let's go down and remove the
last
one two three four five so we are going
to remove the last
seven rows from the table
so again I'll go to reduce rows and
click on remove rows now this time I'll
select remove bottom rows
and here I'll choose
I want to delete seven rows from the
table
from the bottom
I click on OK
if you see
the last seven rows have been deleted
now let me show you the last row which
is this one
so the last season of
UEFA Champions League was held in 2020
which is this year
and Bayern Munich won the Champions
League against
a French team that was Paris Saint
Germans by a score of 1-0
now if you see the last value that is
the attendance
2 is 0 which means there were no
Spectators in the stadium it was because
of the covet conditions
and let's do some more manipulation to
our data suppose this time I want to add
a new column let's say a stadium name by
extracting values from the venue column
so let me just show you the venue column
so this is our venue column so the first
value is the stadium name
then we have the city in which the
stadium is there
and finally we have the
country name
so I want to extract only the stadium
name so you can see we have some
stadiums like Santiago bernabao
this Wembley Sans 0
and other stadiums so I want to extract
only the stadium names
so let's see how to do that
I'll click on the venue column and go to
add column tab
under add column here you can see we
have extract if I click on this drop
down there is an option to select
text before delimiter so if I choose
text before delimiter
here
I'll give my delimiter as comma
so everything before the first comma
will be considered as the stadium name
now let me click on OK
now here you can see under applied steps
it says inserted
text before delimiter if I scroll to the
right you can see the last column
has our stadium names
let me double click on this and change
this to
stadium name column
and hit enter even this step is applied
here you can see renamed columns
similarly
let's explore a few more features
now I want to add a new column called
Stadium City
so if you consider this venue column
whatever is there between the two commas
is the stadium city so for example
Santiago bernabao is in Madrid similarly
Wembley Stadium is in London sancero is
in Milan so these middle values I want
to extract into a new column called as
Stadium City
so let's see how to do it so I'll click
on the menu column and go to extract and
again I'll select
the extract tab
and here now I'll choose
text between delimiters
and my first delimiter I'll give is a
comma
and a space you can see here all the
values
have a comma and a space
and my ND limiter will be another comma
then I'll click on OK this will add a
new column
to the extreme right of the table you
can see here we have text between
delimiters and it has extracted the
stadium city
let me go ahead and rename this
column as Stadium
City and hit enter
you can see the applied step here
now
I want to split the score column into
two columns so here we have the score
column and
the left value presents the number of
goals that were scored by the winning
team and the right value presents the
number of
goals that were scored by the losing
team
so here I'll split the column into two
columns as winner score and loser score
so what I'll do is
select this column and go to the Home
tab under the Home tab we have split
column
I'll select split column and then choose
by delimiter
so automatically Excel power query
detects that this Dash is my delimiter
and I'll split at each occurrence of the
delimiter
let's click on OK
now you can see
the score column has been split into two
it has renamed the column as score.1 and
score.2
what I'll do is I'll go ahead and
we'll rename this column as winner score
and this will
rename it to Loser score
I'll hit enter
and I have renamed it successfully
next
let's change the windows team and the
runner sub team values to uppercase
so suppose I want to change all the
values or the club names of the winners
team to upper case so what I can do is
I'll select this column and go to the
transform tab under transform tab I have
this option called
format
so here
I'll click on format and then
you can see I can change the case to
lowercase uppercase capitalize each word
so here I want to make all the winner
teams as uppercase I'll select uppercase
there you go we have successfully
converted all the winner team names to
uppercase
similarly let's do it for the runner sub
team as well
so here I have my Runner sub team I'll
go to the transform tab click on format
and select uppercase
now we saw
how to do some simple
manipulation of our data so we created a
few columns split a few columns
now to save all this I have to go to the
Home tab and then click on close and
load
foreign
this will take some time and load our
data onto this Excel sheet
you can see here it's loading the data
this will take a bit of time there you
go
Excel power query feature has
successfully
performed some manipulations on our data
some calculations on our data and then
it has saved the final version and
loaded it on to excel Now using this
clean data we can do some analysis let's
say I want to find the seasons in which
the winners team scored more than three
goals so we have a problem statement at
hand we want to find the seasons in
which the winner team had more than
three goals scored
so what you can do is select any cell in
this data and go to the insert tab and
click on pivot table
here I'll click on existing worksheet
and then I'll give my location
I'll place my
pivot table somewhere here and click on
OK
all right now
since I want to know the seasons I'll
drag season onto row
and I'll also drag
the Winner's team
column onto rows
then I'll choose my winner score under
values
here you can see we have the pivot table
ready
now we need to filter this table to see
all the winning teams that scored more
than three goals so what I'll do is
I'll select this winner score column and
place it under filters
and here you can see I have my filter
let me click on this drop down
and I'll select multiple items
from this multiple items I'll choose 4 5
and 7 because these values are greater
than 3 and click on OK
here you can see I have filtered my
pivot table and left you can see the
season
and the winner team that had scored more
than three goals in the finals
all right
similarly
you can perform some more analysis
suppose I want to know how many times
Real Madrid won the championship so
let's see
I'll click on one cell in the data set
go to the insert Tab and click on pivot
table
I'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location here
let's say I want to place my pivot table
here
I click on OK
all right so the question we have is how
many times have Real Madrid won the
championship so I'll choose
the Winner's team column and place it
under rows
and
let's see
we'll select the winner score as well
and let's convert this winner score from
sum
to let's say count and click on OK and
since I want to check only for Real
Madrid
so what I'll do is I'll go to
the insert tab and I'll insert a slicer
here I'll choose
winner teams as my slicer and click on
OK
and out of this I want to choose only
Real Madrid so I'll select Real Madrid
you can see it here
Real Madrid have won the championship 13
times
okay let's say you want to compress your
data and remove unnecessary columns
without losing any information you can
do that using a feature in the power
query editor called unpivot
to perform this task we'll use a census
data of India from Wikipedia so let me
first show you the Wikipedia page
so this is my Wikipedia article which
says list of states in India bypassed
population
and if I scroll down
you can see it here there's a table
which says by past population from 1947
to 2011.
so there are a few columns like rank
this state or Union territory and we
have population starting from 1951 till
2011 which was our last census
here you can see if I scroll further
there are
nearly 29 States and we have
seven union territories so we will
extract this table and load into Excel
first
okay so let me click on a new sheet
and we'll follow the same drill I'll go
to my data tab
and click on get data under get data
I'll go to from other sources and click
on from web
here it will ask me to provide the URL
link of the Wikipedia page so I'll paste
the URL here and click on OK
now once I have done that
it will load a few tables
onto Excel you can see there are a few
tables here I'll click on the first one
so we have our table here
now let's do some transformation to this
data
this opens in the power query editor
okay I'll click on refresh first
this will take some time to refresh the
entire data okay we are done now if you
see this data clearly
the first row in this table is not
necessary at all because these are our
column names so we also have our column
headers already present so let's go
ahead and delete the first row so we'll
go to the Home tab under remove rows
I'll click on remove top rows
now I'll give my
number of rows as 1 so we want to remove
the first row only I'll click on OK
you can see the first two has been
deleted
if I scroll further
I actually don't need the last row as
well which is the total
so what we can do is we can also remove
the last row from the bottom
so I'll
select one
click on OK
you can see the step has been applied
and
you don't see the last row that was the
total row anymore
so the task that I want to do here is
I want to compress
all these columns which are basically
the population columns
so I'll
select my
state or Union territory column
and go to the transform Tab and here I
have the option to unpivot columns so
I'll click on this drop down and select
unpivot other columns
you can see here the step has been
applied and
all the population column from 1951 till
2011 have been unpivoted if you want you
can go ahead and
rename these columns let's say I'll
write it as population column
and
let's say this is
I'll rename it to total population value
all right
now we are done with our preparation of
data let's go to the Home tab and click
on close and load
now this will take some time to load the
data onto Excel
all right so we have our Census Data
here so first you can see
rank 1 is uttar Pradesh and we have the
population starting from 1951 till 2011
then we have for Maharashtra
if I scroll down you can see the other
states we have Tamil Nadu Rajasthan this
Karnataka if I scroll further
we have odisha this Telangana Kerala now
if you see here the population values
from 1951 till 2011 for the Telangana
state are all n a which means there was
no data available
now this is because Telangana was only
formed in 2014 so there was no census
for this state
let's continue with our demo and let's
explore a few more features and
functionalities of our query editor
now the next table we are going to use
is an adventure Works customer table
now this data set is provided by
Microsoft for practitioners who want to
learn power bi Excel or similar
Technologies and want to do some
manipulation some calculation some data
analysis stuff
so let me go to a new sheet and let's
import
the adventureworks customer data set
it's a CSV file onto Excel first so I'll
go to my data tab
and click on get data from here I'll go
to
from file and choose
from Text slash CSV
you can see it here in my power query
files folder I have my Adventure Works
customer table
I'll select this and click on import
this will take some time to load the
data set
you can see the preview of the data set
here so we have
columns like the customer key we have
the prefix of the customer name the
first name the last name of the customer
date of birth
marital status
if I go to the right we have annual
income total children education level
occupation and homeowner column as well
so let's click on transform data
here we'll learn a few more
features of our query
okay we have our data on our power query
editor
so first what I'll show you is
let's change the prefix column the first
name column and the last name column to
proper case
so you can see it here the prefix first
name and last name columns are all in
uppercase now if you want to change the
values to proper case
just
hit Ctrl and select the three columns
and
go to the transform tab
under transform tab you have format
so if you click on format here you can
see we have lowercase uppercase now
proper case is to capitalize each word
so I'll click on capitalize each word
you can see it here now
we have converted the prefix first name
and last name column
into prop keys The Next Step I'm going
to show you is let's merge all the three
columns the prefix column the first name
column and the last name column into one
full name column so
what I'll do is I'll select the three
columns
and then let's go to add column
and under add column we have this option
called merge columns
let's hit merge columns
okay
now it's asking you to give the
separator I'll select my separator as a
space
and click on OK
so before click on OK I want to change
my
new column name from merged to let's say
full name
and now let's click on OK
you can see here it says inserted merged
column and if I go to my
right
you can see it here we have a full name
column now if you want
to shift the location of the full name
column you can do that as well
just
hold this and keep on dragging to the
left
this will move the entire
table to the right and you can place it
wherever you want so I want to place it
let's say here
okay
now actually I don't want all these
columns so let's delete it
so click on this and I'll right click
I click on remove
you can see we have removed the prefix
column similarly let's remove the other
two columns you can either right click
and do or go to the Home tab and then
select remove columns
all right
now
let's say we want to add a domain name
column from AWS customers by extracting
the characters between at the rate
and.com
so actually I'm talking about the email
address
from this email address we want to
create a new column called as domain
name for that we'll extract characters
that are present between at the rate
and.com
so let's see how to do it
I'll select the email address column and
then I'll go to add column under add
column I'll click on extract
and this time we want to extract
between two delimiters also I'll select
text between delimiters and I'll give my
starting delimiter as at the rate
and my end delimiter would be.com
now let's click on OK
so this will insert a new column to the
extreme right you can see we have our
domain name
let's go ahead and
change the column name to domain name
and hit enter
all right you can see the step has been
applied
now we are done with
our preparation of customer stable let's
just go to the Home tab and click on
close and load
so all the transformation that we did in
the power query editor
will reflect here so you can see we have
our full name column
and if you see
we have our domain name as well
okay
Now using the power query editor you can
perform some
statistical analysis now let's explore
those statistical features
for this we'll be using another data set
called adventurebox product data set
again this data set is also provided by
Microsoft
so let's go to the new sheet and here
I'll go to the data tab
click on get data
under from files I click on Text slash
CSV here you can see we have Adventure
Works products I click on import
let's click on transform data
so we have our data
loaded on to the power query editor
the data is mostly clean
alter this data let's straight away go
ahead and explore some of the
statistical features that we have here
now let's see
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the product table
we have this product name column and say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the table
how to do it
so what you can do is click on this
product name column then go to the
transform tab now in the transform tab
you have an option called statistics
click on this drop down and select count
values
now this will open another window
that will return the total number of
products in the table you can see the
value here it says 293
now to move back to the query editor so
let's just click cancel or close
we are back again
all right
now let's say you want to calculate the
average product price from the product
table so if I move to the right
you have a column called Product price
so let's see what is the average product
price from the product table so I'll
select this product price column go to
the transform tab under statistics I'll
select average
so this will give me the average product
price which is
714.4373 you can consider any unit you
want let's say this is in dollars
now then we have to cancel this step to
move back
okay
now if you want to find the maximum
minimum product price you can do that as
well so let me select my column
product price and go to the transform
tab under the transform tab
we'll click on this status drop down
and let's say I'll select minimum so
this will give me the minimum product
price which is 2.29 similarly
if you want to find the maximum product
price so select this product price
column go transform Tab and then choose
maximum
so this is the maximum product price in
the product table we have
let's cancel this step
okay
now you can also round the product cost
and product price column to two decimal
places so if I show you both the columns
you have your product cost and you have
the product price column you can see the
floating values or the decimal points
are not constant it's varying so let's
limit it to two decimal places what you
can do is Select both the columns and
then go to the transform tab
in the transform tab you have here
rounding
I click on this drop down and select
round
now here I'll give my decimal places as
2.
if I click on OK
you can see here both the columns the
product cost and the product price
column have been rounded up to two
decimal places
I can scroll down you can see
all the values have been rounded up to
two decimal places
all right
now let's say you want to add a column
called discount price column by
multiplying 0.9 to the product price
column and let's say you also want to
round that new column to two decimal
places so how to do it
so we want to give a discount of 10
percent so I'll select this product
price column
and then I'll choose custom column
here we'll write a formula
so I'll give my new column name as
discount price
and my formula would be
I'll select product price
I'll click on insert
and then I'll multiply this product
price by
0.9
so this will give me my 10 discount
on the product price and click on OK
you see here we have a new column added
which is Discount price
so
If the product price is 34.99 if you
give a 10 discount
it's 31.491
all right
now the next question was to change the
or around the decimal places to 2
so go to the transform tab under
rounding I'll click on round
let's see I'll give two and click on OK
so even this has rounded the discount
price column to two decimal places
now we are done with our math before
making any English United States instead
of English India
so I'll just scroll down
and here we have right click on OK
now once this is done I'll go to my data
type and I'll select date as my data
type
I'll choose replace current
okay now you can see my date column has
been formatted the date tab you can see
I have access to all this operations on
this date column column
go to add column
here under add column I have
selectors so I'll click on this dinner
day
let's say I click on close and load
now this will load the
data set onto Excel you can see it here
we have the data ready now you can use
this data to make some analysis
draw a pivot table draw a pivot chart
and do whole lot of things now while
working on a project it is possible that
not all your data will be in a single
file it could be stored in multiple
files so it's important to combine and
bring all your data together
now we will see how to join your data
vertically
I have my data present in a CSV folder
so let me show you the folder first
so this is my CSV folder let me open it
and I have some files these are named as
project one two three four and five let
me open just one of the project files it
has a very small quantity of data
you can see it has a month column and an
amount column let me close this
and
let me show it to you again let's open
project four
all the files have the same number of
columns you can see this also has a
month column and an amount column
now we'll combine all this data together
and load it into Excel let's see how to
do it so I'll open a new sheet
and I'll go to my data Tab and click on
get data then I'll go to from file and
this time I'll choose from folder
now this will ask me to give
you can see it here it says sheet1
okay
now it's processing all the data files
present in that CSV folder
and this will be uploaded onto our power
query editor
now you can see here on the power query
editor
all my
data files have been combined vertically
here you can see the month column
on the extreme right it's the amount
column and to the extreme left we have
the source name or the
source file where the data came from so
first is Project one then we have
project two if I scroll down we have
project three files project four and
similarly we have project five
now this is one way in which you can
merge your tables vertically
so we are done with it let's just go to
the Home tab and click on close and load
all the Transformations that were
applied you can see it here we have our
final table
and we have successfully
combined
five Excel files
again
you can also join your data horizontally
this would be like an SQL join where the
data is present in multiple files or
sheets based on a common key column you
can join the tables so you can perform a
left join a right join an inner joint
based on the problem that you are trying
to solve so let's merge two tables based
on a column
I'll show the data set first it's an
Excel file which has three worksheets
so here is my Excel file which we'll be
using to
merge our data horizontally you can see
there are three worksheets
the first one is year 11 which has data
regarding the student name the gender of
the student and the course the student
had opted for
similarly we have another for 2012 or
year 12 we have the student name gender
as well as the course
and finally we have a courses table or a
courses sheet which has all the details
regarding the course
so we have the course name the teacher
who teaches or teacher who taught that
course we have the lesson type the
number of credits and the assignment
type now we'll use this data sets
to load it onto Excel using power query
so I am on my Excel sheet let's just
open a new sheet I'll go to the data Tab
and here I'll click on get data and this
time I'll choose
from Excel workbook
and I'll select my file which is
students and courses I click on import
so we'll just see how to import two
tables and join them horizontally
so let me first select the courses sheet
and I'll click on transform data
now this has loaded the courses table
onto power query editor the table looks
fine we have the course column teacher
everything is fine now let's load one
more table and then we'll merge it so
here under the Home tab you have
a section called new source I'll click
on file I'll again select my students
and courses and click on import
and this time let's choose
another table let's say year 11 which
has the column name as student gender
and course
I click on OK
it has successfully loaded this table
onto power query editor
now if you say this
the first row is actually our
column names so I'll go to the Home tab
and select use first row as headers
so this will push the first row
to the column names you can see we have
done it successfully we have my student
name the gender column and the course
column
now let's merge it so
if you see here in the Home tab we have
a section called merge queries
let's click on this drop down and select
merge queries
here I have my table which is year 11
and let's choose one more table that is
courses
now the kind of join
I'll choose as left outer join which
means it will take all the rows from the
first table and matching records from
the second table
here I need to select the common key
column so if you see both the tables we
have the course column as the common key
column so I'll select
this and now you can see there's a tick
mark which means it has selected the
rows and the column successfully you can
see it says the selection matches 175
175 rows from the first table
and let's click on OK
let's just expand this
and click on OK
if I scroll to the right you can see I
have successfully merged
both the tables
now if you want
you can remove unnecessary
rows or columns suppose if you see I
have the course column
from the year 11 table and here also I
have
the course column now this is
redundant let's just remove one of the
columns I'll just select this column
I'll go to
remove columns and I'll select remove
columns
okay
the rest looks fine we have successfully
merged both the tables by using a left
outer join
let's just click close And load
now this will take some time to load our
data onto Excel you can see it here we
have successfully loaded it onto Excel
now we are done with our demo part
now let's just see what all we have done
in our demo so I'll
go to my first sheet here you can see
we had imported a simple
text file first and then we plotted a
graph which is a pivot chart
then you saw
how to upload
a file from the web so here we imported
a UFO Champions League table which was
present on Wikipedia and then we plotted
some
graphs and charts you can see we made
analysis using pivot tables
and then we imported another web file
which was based on a population data and
we used the unpivot option or the
unpivot feature in the power query to
reduce the number of columns
then we made some calculations to our
customer table which was from Adventure
works
then we used another table
called the products table here we saw
some statistical calculations and we
added a column called discount price
where we used conditional operations
and then you saw how we manipulated a
date column
and then we saw how to append and merge
multiple tables in this video we'll be
creating two dashboards using a sample
sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comment section of the video a
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in Excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards
an advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with Comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding let's jump into
our demo for creating our dashboards
we'll be using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo
so this data set was actually generated
using a simulator and is completely
random it was not validated though we
have applied certain transformations to
the data using power query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly if I go on top you can see
this data set has 17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have Middle East and
North Africa this North America Asia
sub-Saharan Africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items Cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits
Etc
then we have the representative's name
or you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales Channel column so
there are basically two channels whether
the item was sold offline or online
next we have the order priority column
now here C stands for critical then we
have H which is for high priority orders
then we have M for medium priority
orders and finally we have L which is
for low priority orders
you can see the order date column then
we have the order ID the ship date next
we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which each product was
sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column now
the total cost column is actually the
product of units sold and the unit cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally we have created two more
columns that is order year and then we
have order month now these two columns
were actually generated using the power
query features so we use the order date
column which is this column and
extracted order year and Order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate po tables and po
charts and format them to make them look
more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this I'll click on a cell in my data set
and then I'll go to the insert tab here
we have the option to select the pivot
table
I click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next I want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on OK
there you go so we have a new sheet
where I can place my pivot table
so first I need to find the total
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is
I'll drag my order here column
under rows and then
I'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see I have my Pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order Year from 2010 to 2017.
now based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so I'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this
now actually I want a line chart so I'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go so we have successfully
created our first pivot chart
now let me show you how you can format
this chart to make it more readable
so first let me delete
these so I'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the buttons present on
the chart now let me go ahead and edit
the chart title
so the title I want is total revenue
I'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if I click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines Legend and others
Okay so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we label our x-axis
and y axis so here under x axis
I can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis I'll put Revenue
okay now you can move a bit
all right now
let me select this chart Style option
and go to Colors first
here I'll select yellow color okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
I want
this style
okay
now you can also add
data labels so I'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if I click on this Arrow here I have
more options
if I scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
I'll expand this
and under category I'll select custom
now here
will give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so I'll write if my Revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
000.
let me make sure there are six nines
here so one two three four five and six
okay we are good to go
I'll close the bracket
I'll give a hash
give two commas
so if the revenue is greater than 9
lakhs 99
000 I'll put it in the format of
millions So within double quotes I'll
write m
I'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be 0 million let me click on
ADD
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data and you see here we
have I'll select custom
and
we'll use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go we
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can reduce the font size or
increase the font size let me just show
you suppose you want to increase the
font size of the chart title so you just
select it and from here you can either
reduce or you can increase you can see
now it's 12 if you want you can make it
16. similarly you can also edit the
access labels also by selecting the
chart title you can also move it to left
or right or you can place it in the
center as the time being let me just
keep it to the left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and will create a combo
chart for this so let me show you how to
do it
I'll go to my data sheet
I have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on OK all right
so for this
I'll select
my region onto rows
and then
I'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column all right so here we have
the pivot table ready now based on this
pivot table let's create our pivot chart
so I'll go to recommended charts and if
you see below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on OK
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is the bars
represent the total revenue which is
this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next we'll add data labels so I'll click
on data labels here okay so these are
the data labels for
the bars or the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so I'll click on this Arrow go
to more options
if I scroll down
I have number
from here I'll select custom and
I'll choose my type that is in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our data
next thing we'll add a chart title
so here I'll write as
Revenue
by
region
it's actually revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well I'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet 3 also I am going to rename it as
Revenue
go to the data sheet and create our
pivot table first
I click on OK
now
I'll select order priority under rows
and under values I'll select total
revenue
so this is a very simple pivot table so
you have your order priority so C is for
critical H is for high L is for low and
Ms you can see the different country
names and we have the
Revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally we'll create another report
which is going to be part of our Revenue
dashboard and this is revenue by items
so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits this cloths
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these items
so we'll continue the same drill I'll
create my PO table on a new worksheet
and this time I'm going to drag
item type under rows and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different item names and
then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so
you can see here office supplies meet
the highest amount of Revenue
followed by household then cosmetics and
fruits meet the lowest amount of Revenue
I'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts this time I am
going to create a bar chart so this is
how my bar chart is going to look like
I'll select OK all right now let's
format this chart a bit
I'll delete the field buttons and I'll
delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
Revenue
by
items cool
we also want to change the
color of the bars so I've selected all
the bars I'll go to my home Tab and here
let's say I want to select green color
all right
I've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
and I'll remove the Bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
Also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet
and first thing I'm going to do is
I'll click on The View Tab and uncheck
grid lines so this will remove
the grid lines present in the worksheet
next
I am going to insert an image so we'll
have a background image on our dashboard
so the way to do is I'll go to the
insert Tab and under illustrations I
have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so I'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
I'll go to desktop and here I have a
folder called Excel dashboard files
and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so I'll hit shift and I'll drag it
foreign
so you can see I have successfully added
a background image if you want you can
still
expand this background image a bit to
the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so I'll click
on insert and here
I have the option to select a text box
so
I'll click on a text box and
I'm going to place a text box in the
middle
and I'm going to name this text box as
Excel
Revenue dashboard
on sales
I'll
Center Line at
let's do some more formatting so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see shape format
here I'm going to expand this shape fill
and I'll select no fill
so my text box is transparent now and
I'll also remove the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and I'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to Britannica bold
and I'll increase the size to let's say
all right I'll just
drag the text box
I'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so I'll go to
insert and I'll click on illustrations
again and select pictures
I am going to add
these two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing so I'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and I'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so I'll hit
Ctrl V to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see I have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts are
column charts the combo charts the Spy
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered so let's adjust
the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the white background from
each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart
then I'll right click and go to format
chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called No fill so if I select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now similarly let me also remove
the grid lines so I'll select the grid
lines and hit delete so I've also
removed the grid lines from here now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so I'll select this chart go to
format and here
I'll go to shape outline and I'll select
no outline you see this so we have our
total revenue by year which is a line
chart and this is completely transparent
now now what I'm going to do is
I'll place this chart over a box
so I'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so I'll
click on illustrations and here I'll
choose a shape and let me select a
rectangle
so I'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to front
I'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and I'll place this shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first I'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and and let me increase the transparency
so I'll
right click and go to format shape here
I'll increase the transparency let's
keep it to
25 percent
or let's say
20 percent all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the access labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better now we'll just adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so I'll go to shape
outline and I'll select no outline you
see
we have now formatted our chart let's
just
pull this a little up
all right now we'll add this blue
background to all the other charts so
we'll first add the background make it
transparent and then we'll convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible so
for the time being I'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens we have nicely formatted our
dashboard
so I've added a few logos for each of
the charts you can see the logos here so
for
Revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the labels
in terms of Millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year in region are all
formatted in terms of Millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by Revenue in terms of
millions so the way to do is you can
select this graph
right click and go to format access
here if I scroll down
you have numbers
and
under category I'll select custom
then I'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to our
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see Revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add date columns
so if you want to see what was the
amount of sales or revenue generated on
a particular year or a particular month
you can do that using a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts
and then either you can go to the insert
Tab and here you can see under filters
we have slices and timeline or if you go
to the pivot chart analyze tab
here also you have insert slicer and
timeline option so I'll select insert
slicer here first now it's giving me the
list of
Fields present in the data set so I'll
select
country
region and let's say we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers I'll click on OK
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have Asia
this Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slicers
and then for item type also we have all
the items that were present in our data
set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slicers to a dashboard so what
I'll do is
I'll right click
on this option
and I'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to select
all the pivot tables so let me check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on OK
all right now that we have connected one
of our slices we'll now connect the
other remaining slicers
so I'll right click on this go to report
connections and I'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on OK
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer I'll go to report connections and
let me select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have the item type so
I'll right click
good report connections and then I'll
select all my Pivot tables
and let's hit OK
all right now let me just organize this
a bit so I'll
place my Pivot tables
to the right
I'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
I'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
I'll add my final slicer that is sales
Channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be the profit dashboard I'll show you
how to add a timeline
all right
now I have arranged all my slicers
so let's say you want to find the
revenue that was generated for an item
type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for beverages
item type
if I scroll down
this chart represents the revenue that
was generated in each of the countries
only for item type beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
India
so I have selected India here
and now you can see
My Graph has changed only for
country India
you can see here it is showing only for
India now
similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to know the revenue
generated based on sales channel so we
have two sales channel that is offline
and online suppose we want to know the
revenue generated offline so I'll just
select offline you can see the values
have changed so these were the revenues
generated for each of the items only for
offline
if you
see here now these were all the offline
seals for the different regions
so
this is
our entire Excel Revenue dashboard on
sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied different formatting we
added different icons then we formatted
the labels also next we added slicers
and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this sheet as
Revenue dashboard I'll write Rev
dashboard okay
now we'll move to our data sheet and
start creating your pivot tables and po
charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table so
I'll create a new worksheet
this time I'm going to create a line
chart to visualize the profit for each
year
so I'll drag my
total profit column two values and my
order here to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to get an idea as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since I've
sorted this data in descending order so
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do Ctrl Z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my PO chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart
I'll click on OK
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first I'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart and I'll
rename the chart title as total
profit
by year
next I am going to remove the legend so
I'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
I'll go to style
and
this time
I'm going to select
my style type okay and if you want you
can
choose the colors as well for the time
being let's have
this yellow color
next let me add the data labels so again
if you see here this is not formatted
properly so let's go ahead and format
the
data labels so I'll click on number
and I'll select custom here
and the type I'm going to select is in
millions and I'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next
we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this I am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table so I'll
go to insert and I'll click on pivot
table
let me click on OK
since I want the country names so I'll
select country under rows and then I
have
my total profit under values
the next thing I'm going to do is I'll
just rename the row labels as
countries
and then
I'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
I'm going to select this pivot table go
to the design tab here we have subtotals
in Grand totals I'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again I'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right I'm going to
select my data
copy it
'll go on top
and I'll paste it here
using this data I can create my field
map now so I'll go to insert here we
have the option to create a field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
I can expand this
as you can see our map has a color scale
which comes from light gray color to
dark blue color
so the countries that are in Gray or you
can see light blue
have the lowest amount of profit while
the regions or the countries that have
been shaded in
dark color a dark blue color have
highest amount of profit
I will go ahead and delete this scale
okay
next we need to connect this map to the
original data source so what I do is
I'll right click on this map and I'll go
to select data here instead of the
previous range I'll give my new Range
now so
my new range
will be my original po table that I had
created
and go on top and click on OK
so we have our
map ready now now if you want you can
change the color of the shade so I'll
just go to colors and let's see we'll
keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made least amount
of profit
okay now moving on
next
we want to create a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales Channel so for this we
are going to create another line chart
so I'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so I'll select new worksheet here
since I want to know the profit by year
first of all I'll drag my order here
column to rows
and then
I'll choose my total profit column under
values
next I'm going to select my sales
Channel under columns there you go so we
have our pivot table here
now based on this pivot table let me
create my Pivot chart so I'll go to
recommended charts and I'm going to
create a line chart
I close this
you see here
based on this chart you can tell
The Profit generated with
online sales were actually lower than
that of offline so here the Blue Line
represents offline profit and the Orange
Line represents Online Profit
if you Mark Clearly
in year 2012 the Online Profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
I'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and add
a chart title so I'll write
profit
by
year and
sales Channel
okay
so this is my
second report before moving ahead let me
just
rename this sheet so I'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say SC for sales Channel
okay
moving ahead
now I want to create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
The Profit by sales Channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
I'll first go to insert click on pivot
table and click on OK
so I'll drag my sales Channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table now
let's create our pivot chart which is
going to be a pie chart let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so I'm going to select a donut
chart here I click on OK
let's
edit this chart I'll remove the field
buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
I'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales Channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again I am going to
format this label
I'll select the category as custom and
my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
I'll write
profit
by
let's say C which stands for sales
Channel
cool
finally I am going to create a report
that will show the revenue and profit by
items
so I'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first
this time I'll choose my
total profit under values
and we'll also have the revenue column
so I'll put my Revenue at the top
then I'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the Orange Line represents
the total profit
I'll click on OK
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title I'll name
it as
Revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use for our profit
dashboard
next let's create a new sheet and we'll
get started with building our dashboard
so I'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
will continue with the previous drill
so first of all let's go to the view Tab
and remove the grid lines
now
will insert a background image
like we did for our Revenue dashboard so
I'll go to insert under illustrations
I'll click on pictures and select this
device
I am going to have the same background
I'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just drag this
a bit to the right
will adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard
so here you can see I have brought my
Revenue dashboard
and I'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
I'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
Excel
profit dashboard instead of renew now
we'll copy each of the charts that we
just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales Channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard so
let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
and copy this as well
similarly I'll bring the other three
charts onto my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard I have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
I have also made some formatting for
example I have reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so I'll
select the first chart I'll right click
and I'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill I'll select no fill
next I am going to remove the grid line
so I'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so I'll go to design
actually format and I'll remove the
outline
next I am going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and I'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and I'll bring this to front
and I'll move this
to the back
next I'm going to change the font color
all to White
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
I'll do it for the x axis as well okay
so here I have my first
chart ready the same I'm going to do for
the rest of the charts
okay so now you can see here I have
formatted all my charts I have also
added a blue background
you see here I have also formatted the
y labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit similarly here I
have added the data labels this is for
Revenue
some of the charts also have the data
Legend so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
I've also formatted the map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our slicers as
well as timeline first let me show you
how to add a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts and
I'll go to insert under insert I have
the option to create a timeline
so I'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so Excel has only
shown us two columns so I am going to
create my timeline based on order date
so I'll select my order date column and
I'll click on OK
you can see here this is called a
timeline I can expand this now this
timeline is based on months now and if I
scroll this timeline you can see here I
have my order year 2010 and I have all
the 12 months similarly we have for 2011
then we have for 2012 all the way till
2017. now you can filter this in terms
of years quarters months or days let me
just select year now
so I have
years from 2010 till 2017 let me just
squeeze this and I'll place it somewhere
here on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so I
have selected one of the charts
under insert I'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which I want to create
slicers so I'll create region
let me also select country
let's say I want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and I'll click on OK
so here I have created three slicers
let me
first resize it and
I'll place it
on the right
support so I'm going to click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here I'm going to
select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here I have selected four and I need
one more which is view table number 10
if I click on OK
similarly let's create or connect my
region filter to all the pivot tables so
I right click go to report connections
here I'll
choose all my Pivot tables which are
based on profit
I'll click on OK
let's do it for the conflict
all the pivot tables related to profit
then I'll click on OK
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so I am
selecting one of the pivot charts I'll
go to insert click on slicer and I'll
select sales Channel and hit OK
so I have my sales Channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on OK
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing I want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017 suppose
you want to know the profit that was
generated in the year 2012 so I'll just
click on this range and now you can see
our
charts only show information for 2012 so
this dot represents there was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
The Profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit each of these countries made in
if I scroll down you can see the revenue
and profit by items
no if I select
another year let's say 2013 I can just
drag this to the right and now you can
see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
Excel has prompted all right so this is
how you can use a timeline now as I said
be checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
I'll
send it back to the place where it was
and I'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose you want to check the profit
made by different Representatives you
can select them one by one let's say
Adam Churchill
this is the
profit generated by Adam Churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer let me just bring
this to the middle and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart I'll
just bring this to the front so that you
can see it clearly okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say United Kingdom you can
select United Kingdom so this is the map
of United Kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
United Kingdom and
below you can see
the revenue and profit for all the items
that was sold in
United Kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item meet the highest
amount of profit in
United Kingdom now you can also select
multiple countries let's say I want to
know for France as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now I
have
United Kingdom and France selected and
the other charts present in my dashboard
change accordingly now I have my
country selected as India you can see
the map of India here
and these were the respective profit
values now one thing to note here is
this is actually not millions that
should be in K that is Thousands so
please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually K and
naught million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables and
pivot charts and then we formatted our
po charge based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing you can also
change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select another theme let's say face it
you see the colors have changed and it
looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic you see a chart
has changed let me just delete this okay
so now once you change the theme the
text also change a bit you can see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore One More theme let's say
this time I am going to choose
depth
and this is more
of a green type of color
you can play around and select
what about theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my Revenue
dashboard and see how it looks there you
go so since we changed our theme even
our Revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and play with
different themes colors fonts and
effects all right so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created line charts this combo chart pie
chart horizontal and vertical bar charts
and then we learned how to add slicers
and connected to different pivot tables
and we filtered our data to see
Revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales Channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more
let's quickly see some more examples of
doing data analysis using Excel and for
that we can use some inbuilt add-ins
which can be added to our Excel sheet so
for example if you would want to do a
descriptive analytics or descriptive
analysis on your data say for example
getting your descriptive statistics such
as your mean median mode and so on so we
can do that and we can use Excel for it
so for example you can if you are given
some data say I have temperature price
of ice cream units sold and I would want
to have descriptive statistics on this
what I can do is I can click on file and
here in file you can click on options
and within options click on add-ins now
within add-ins you have Excel add-ins
which is selected here so click on say
go for example in that shows what
add-ins are available and you can choose
which ones are you interested in so for
example I have chosen analysis tool pack
and solver add-in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your Excel so if you click on data so
here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis and here it says what are you
interested in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histograms so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok now
this one basically asks your input range
so while your cursor is blinking here
also it is said grouped by so let's give
it a range so for example I will say say
temperature
now if I do this and I have selected The
Heading just look at that and now you
need an output range so let's just
select this and then you can have your
cursor blinking in here let's select say
Fields here and this is where I would
want the output now it also said what
options do you want so it has output
range we can then select summary
statistics confidence level so I will
say summary statistics is what I'm
interested in say okay and this says
input input range contains non-numeric
data now why is that because we chose
temperature The Heading also so click on
OK and here we will alter the range so
this one is our range should be only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on OK
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here I could basically
given a value for this so I can say
temperature and that's my descriptive
statistics for temperature might be I
can just do some formatting and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here now
similarly we can do it for price of ice
cream so what we need is we need to
basically go for data
data analysis descriptive statistics say
okay now you need to give a range so
here I will change my range to these
values output range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on OK and this says
output range will overwrite existing
data press ok to override data in range
I will say cancel no that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new Range
so let's select our new Range which is
here and now click on OK so now we get
the values which is for your price of
ice cream so again we can basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier I can select this I can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this now I can go into
data and I can go into Data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this B2 to B8 and this
one which is H6 to h19 we would want to
shift it might be two columns up so
maybe I can just say H5 and I can
manually change it to a 17 and let's say
okay
and
we will basically get this and I can get
rid of this so I can have it in the same
range so similarly so this one will have
to be renamed and I can basically say
price of ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold so we would
want to have this now let's see we can
click on data we can click on data
analysis descriptive statistics so we
need to give the range correctly so this
time our range changes to units sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if we were selecting The Heading so
let's do it in this way so in my range
in my range let me empty this I can
basically select this which we know has
non-numeric data in the first row say
for example I'll say labels in first row
I am interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from H to basically something
like J so let's say J and let's select
these values so that should take care of
things and now you see you have your
unit sold you did not have to manually
rename it and you have basically got the
descriptive statistic so this is how you
can simply perform analysis using data
analysis here you can basically get your
descriptive statistics for your columns
and then you can do whatever needed
formatting you need to basically make
your data look
in a
good way now let's look at one more
example of data analysis where we may
want to look at the frequency of values
or frequency of values occurring in a
range of values so for example if you
have been given temperatures you have
been given some pins where you would
want to identify how many values fall
into the range of 0 to 20 20 to 30 30 to
40 40 to 50 and the easiest way to do
that would be creating histogram now
histogram is usually used for data
analysis where you would want to look at
different variables or say features for
example temperature is one such feature
might be there might be one more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see if the
increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find a relationship
between two variables whether they are
positively or negatively related or you
would want to do different kind of
analysis and in certain cases we may
want to First do analysis on one single
variable look at the frequency of values
might we also look at the defects and
for which we can use something like
Pareto chart so we can go for histogram
and that basically gives us the
frequency of values now how do we do
that so we have already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay now I have already
selected input range so if you see here
my input range is temperature which is
also with the headings and I have bin
range which is basically the range of
values so for example I can select this
and that's my bin range I am selecting
or the option labels because I'm using
the first
row which has the heading such as
temperature and pins now we need to give
a output range so for example let's say
I would want my data here and that
becomes my output range so you can have
a sorted histogram or basically a Pareto
chart so if that's what you are
interested in looking at the frequencies
for your different ranges and here I am
also selecting chart output because I
would want to have a visual histogram
which gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on OK and now
you get your bins so it basically tells
you frequency of values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20 so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we
can basically say there is 120 here with
the 20 being the maximum value and then
there is one more 20 so that's your 0 to
20 then you have 20 to 30 which shows
three values so might be in that case I
can say 26
is one thing then I can say 30 that's
the second one and then basically I can
look at 22 so basically this one does
not select 20 as the lower range but it
basically selects 30 as a higher range
so I do see 20 to 30 there are three
entries similarly we can see values of
40 and 50 and since we have selected
Pareto or sorted histogram that shows in
a descending order what is the highest
frequency of values within a particular
range
so that shows me highest frequency is 5
and then you have three and three and
then two so this is how we can create a
histogram and we can perform analysis on
a single variable
now
as discussed earlier as I said sometimes
we may be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables are they linearly
related are they positively related
negatively related and so on and for
that we can use the correlation of your
data analysis add-in so for example you
want to find out correlation of
temperature and units sold and what we
can do is we can find out that using a
formula so for example if I search for
something like Co relation
and let's search so there is a function
called correlation which we can use and
we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me and first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select the range of values
for temperature and then I am interested
in finding out the correlation of
temperature in units sold so let's
select this and that basically gives me
a range of values it gives me the
correlation value which is 0.2859 say
okay and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in you need to give a
range of value so here we are interested
in temperature and price of ice cream so
let's select temperature and then the
second array or list of values is price
of ice cream let's select that let's
close our bracket and here we have the
correlation value of temperature and the
price of ice cream similarly you may be
interested in finding out temperature
and units sold like what we have done
earlier so we can do the same thing
based on function so this is same as
correlation of temperature in units sold
so I can get rid of this one now how do
I do it using the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into Data we need to go click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this now
that basically needs an input range so
we need the range now I might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
I've selected all the columns here we
will say Group by columns obviously we
need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row as heading now output
range you can just give one simple cell
and that's where your data will start
from or you can give a new workbook so
click on OK and that basically gives
your
that basically gives you a correlation
of your different variables and what are
the values and we can check these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically temperature and price
of ice cream
and that basically shows me
0.96149 you have temperature and units
sold so you have 0.2859 now you can also
look at units sold and say for example
price of ice cream you can look at these
particular values so if I would be
interested in finding out what is the
relationship between these variables I
can easily find using correlation so I
could be basically writing in a formula
here and selecting what are the cells so
here we were selecting A2 and C here we
were selecting A and B now might be I'm
interested in price of ice cream and
units sold and if that's what I'm
interested in then I will give a range
of B2 to B8 C2 to C8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values so it's very simple symbol in
Excel and you can use either the data
analysis tab and get your correlation or
you can use formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to
get some values based on periodic data
that means might be I am interested in
range of values I am interested in
seeing a sample of values for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if I go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which I see here might be I want
to see say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or I
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly I would want to pick
up say three temperature values now how
do I do it so for example here I have
seven values now if I go for periodic
sampling
the sample or periodic sample value
which I need to give has to be lesser
than the total input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here and let's go for data analysis
so we can go for sampling here click on
OK and that needs a range of values so
we will select a22 A8 now I could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case I can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row now here we can go for
number of samples which you are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
I have seven values so what if I select
five so for example if I say 5 that
means
I could just get one value so basically
when I'm saying 5 out of 7 so that's
just giving me out of five I want one
value so I can then just give an output
range so here I can basically select
this cell I'll say OK and now you see it
just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is I have
said 5 it has given me the fifth value
that's your periodic sampling so for
example we want more values so let's
reduce this period to might be 2 which
basically gives me every second value so
I can basically say for example 2 and
say OK and then say okay so that shows
me 26 then you have 35 then you have 40
and then well this one does not have any
more values so that's your periodic
sampling now if you go for random
sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling I'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly I want three values
and I can just give this say okay and
then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this values of
temperature so we can use Excel to do a
simple sampling and we can choose
whether we would want to go for periodic
sampling or random sampling let's
continue learning Excel and how Excel
can be used for data analysis now we
have seen uh sampling histogram
correlation descriptive stats and now
also let's look at regression now what
is regression so when you talk about
statistical modeling regression analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between two or more variables and
basically we would want to look at two
or more variables and basically a
relationship of those variables with the
response or the Target right so for
example if we look at our data here we
have temperature we have price of ice
cream and then we have units sold and we
can go ahead and make predictions so for
example when you look at regression here
you see something like this which is
regression statistics you have Anova you
have different plots which we have here
which is X variable X variable 2 and
then you have normal probability plot
now we have already seen how you can
have your add-in that is data analysis
which helps you in doing different kind
of data analysis here right now how do
we do this so we have our variables here
which is temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression we need to understand which
one of these are independent variables
which one of these are dependent
variables right so when you talk about
your X that's your independent variable
or we can say predictor or explanatory
so when you talk about your independent
variables or as we say predictors or
explanatory variables these are the
factors that might influence the
dependent variable and when you talk
about dependent variable that's your
response or Target that's the main
factor you are trying to understand or
predict so we can plot a scatter plot to
see relationship between variables if
they are linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on we can also get values such as
R square which is coefficient of
determination regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so here is one of the links of
one of my edit other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
Spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
Excel so basically we would want to use
our variables which is temperature price
of ice cream units sold and then get
these plots so what we can do is for
example I can get rid of this
and might be I can just say
no borders and when it comes to these
plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal using your data analysis
add-in tool so we have been given
variables here now as I said when we
talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have multiple variables right so
you might have heard of univariate
analysis by variate analysis and so on
well here we are focusing more on using
Excel
to do our regression analysis so I will
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things as Basics should be known
that when we talk about regression
analysis what does it do it helps you
understand how the dependent variable
changes when one or more independent
variables vary and it basically allows
us to mathematically determine which of
those variables really has an impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so mainly the
goal of the model is to get the smallest
possible sum of squares and draw a line
that comes closest to the data so that's
what we mean by our regression line or
basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points fall on a
regression line if there are residuals
that is points which do not fall on the
regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about
statistics we differentiate between a
simple and multiple linear regression so
you have something called a simple
linear regression models which basically
gives you the relationship between
dependent variable and one independent
variable using a linear function and if
you use two or more variables that is
explanatory variables to predict the
dependent variable we are actually
dealing with multiple linear regression
so if the dependent variable is modeled
as a non-linear function because the
data relationships do not follow a
straight line we have to use non-linear
regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this might
be based on temperature price of ice
cream we would want to find out how many
units were sold now what we can do is we
can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
Excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert you can then choose the
kind of plots which you want and here
you have insert scatter plot so we can
choose this and you can choose the first
option so that gives you a blank layout
and what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want X values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about y
That's your dependent variable or your
response or Target so that is in our
case units sold and X values are 1
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here I can click on this
series X values and then I can select
this
now in y values what I can do is I can
select these and then I can just say
Okay so that shows me that it would be
giving me a regression scatter plot now
let's say okay and we have some points
plotted here now if you would want to
see the impact of one individual
variable such as temperature or price of
ice cream you could as well do that now
what you can also do is you can add more
meaning to this by giving in a title or
you can also go into Quick layout and
you have various options here so you see
it gives you what is the access title
what is the series and I would prefer to
use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your R square and that gives you
your Y and X that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change the chart title to something else
say scatter plot of uh dependent
uh West independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning and we can get
rid of this one so we have series and we
can say what are these points if you
would want to add in Legend if you would
want to do that or I can just get rid of
this and I will keep these values here
which we will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always compare these values so here I
have created a simple scatter plot
and then I can look at dependent West
independent variables
or I could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis so
basically you can hear
say for example just say Y and might be
here I will say x and we can rename that
later now how do we perform data
analysis or get into regression right
now what we would want to do is
we would want to get or we would want to
do the regression analysis to
demonstrate the relationship between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation you might have known
about it so it is basically why when you
say y
equals you can say BX plus a plus c and
this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression where X is your independent
variable Y is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected mean value of y when
all X variables are equal to 0 so
basically on a regression graph that's
the point where line crosses the y axis
and that's your intercept
when you talk about B that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as X changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your sorry
that's basically your random error term
right which is basically the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise right now what we can
do is we can also reduce this
equation to Y is B X plus a and that's
the equation of a line we can look into
this and the linear equation can be
understood mathematically in this way
now how do we do it in Excel so what we
can simply do is uh
here let me
yeah
so we need to get into data and then
here we have our data analysis add in
you can click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression so that's what we would want
to do now we'll say okay now here you
need to give your input y range so as I
said you will have to select the
dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your X and Y so y being your target
that's basically your units sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to X either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so I
will select temperature price of ice
cream and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels right now
we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that so you can say
whether you want it in a new worksheet
or you can just say output range and I
will probably just click here and select
one of the cell here now we can also
choose the other options which we would
want to see as a part of this regression
analysis so basically we have selected
input y range which is your dependent
variable you have selected X range which
is your independent variable and if we
are building a multi regression model
then we
have chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range which is basically on this sheet
and then we can select the residuals so
that basically gives you your residuals
now we can also get your line fit plots
which you were seeing earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots and then basically
just say okay
and let's say okay and that basically
gives you your regression analysis
output so we
basically have your summary output we
also have Anova we have our serial
output that's from the previous one and
basically we can get rid of this that's
not required
I can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these so we have
our normal
let's get rid of these
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
this
and then what we can do is since we had
some existing data it has overwritten so
let me get rid of this and I'll repeat
this step again
and let's say no water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis so we go get into
Data we get into Data analysis we choose
regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c x range is multiple
variables we have gone for labels output
range which we would want to select a
particular cell so let me select this I
am going for a serials line fit plots a
normal probability plots and say okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature here the variable is price
of ice cream right so that's your one
variable and second variable and then
you also have your normal probability
plot now to interpret this or to
understand what we have here where we
look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what Excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
Excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at multiple r value here and we
can
let's also fine tune this one
yeah we have our values here and if you
see we have our R square now we can then
basically look at our multiple R so what
is your multiple R that's your
correlation coefficient which basically
measures the strength of linear
relationship between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient it can be any value between
minus 1 and 1 and its absolute value
indicates the relationship strength
so the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and 0 means no relationship
at all now when you're looking at R
square that is the coefficient of
determination which is used as an
indicator of the goodness of the fit so
it basically shows how many points fall
on the regression line so your R square
value is basically calculated from the
total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now when we talk about looking at the
value of your R square so it is
basically we can be seeing that this is
0.450788 that's the value which I am
talking about so it basically means 45
percent of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words 45
percent of dependent variables that is
your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your X
values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted R square it is the R square
adjustment for the number of independent
variables in the model
so uh you would want to use this value
instead of R square for shows the
Precision of your regression analysis so
the smaller the value the more certain
you can be about your regression
equation so when when we talk about your
R square that represents the percentage
of dependent variables variance that is
explained by the model and standard
error is basically an absolute measure
that shows the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that then you
already know what I'm talking about we
are just seeing how Excel easily helps
us in doing these things now we can also
look at observations here which is
basically the number of observations in
our model which is seven
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your Anova values here
so we basically see DF you have s s m s
f and significance F now to understand
these so basically what we are doing is
or what Excel is doing is it splits the
sum of squares into individual
components that give information about
the levels of variability within your
regression model so when you talk about
your DF that's basically the number of
degrees of freedom associated with the
source of variance you have sum of
squares that is your SS so smaller the
residual SS compared with the total SS
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about Ms that's
your mean Square you have f is basically
the F statistic or you can say uh f-test
for the null hypothesis basically it is
used to test the overall significance of
the model and then you finally have your
significance f which is the P value of f
so uh when we when we usually talk about
simple linear regression the in Anova
part is not
really used or it's rarely used right
but when we look at the significance F
value that gives an idea of how reliably
or statistically significant our results
are so if significance f is less than
0.05 that's 5 percent our model is okay
if it is greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at so you basically have
your intercept here so when you talk
about your intercept temperature price
of ice cream so we know we are looking
at our variables and then we are also
locate looking at our intercept which
basically gives you
more details on your coefficients so the
the main important thing when we talk
about regression analysis is basically
your coefficients it basically enables
you to build a linear regression
equation uh in the form of y equals BX
plus a which I explained earlier and
then basically we can understand our
regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have it shows what
is the predicted units sold and then it
also gives you your residuals so we can
compare the estimated and actual number
of sold umbrellas based on the
observation so we have
11.209 here and if you compare that's
basically 12 the second one is 15 and
here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold and
what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right so obviously there will be or
there would be some difference because
independent variables are never perfect
predictors of your dependent variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values so that's what we see
here in the residual section so for
example when we look at this one which
is 11.209 and the actual is 12 we see
what is the residual and how far is the
predicted value from the actual value
so similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables we
are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically add in
more details to this particular plot and
you also have normal probability plot
which is basically getting your values
from your probability output here so
this is how you can perform a simple
regression analysis and now what you can
do is you can as I said you can
basically be looking at your scatter
plot you can be looking at your y and x
and your R square values right but
remember what are the variables which
you are selecting and then you can
compare these with basically the values
what you see here so remember here I've
chosen my both set of variables and you
can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so it's pretty simple here you can add
more details to your scatter plot or the
plots what we have created or Some
people prefer to do it using formulas so
basically we have some statistical
functions that can help you do linear
regression analysis such as you have
Linux you have slope you have intercept
you have correlation and so on so
basically you can use these particular
functions and what you will have to do
is
you will have to basically go in for a
function if that's what you would want
to do and then you can search for
functions and say for example I'll just
say lynnest and say go and here I have
my function so if I would want to really
use this one I can do that what I will
have to do is then select the variable
so if you just say okay and that
basically says your known y's known X
your constants your stats and basically
you can use the formula also but we are
not covering that here might be in the
later videos we can do that so just try
out and perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of Performing regression
analysis using your data analysis add-in
in Excel in this tutorial we will be
talking about macros used in Excel and
also the Visual Basic application
programming for macros so what is Excel
macro you do certain daily tasks and
daily reports or monthly reports that
you generate and you use data from your
Excel and use scrub data and you
basically have the same things performed
or done on the Excel sheets every time
and every day or monthly or bi-weekly or
any number of times that you open your
Excel you remove certain columns you add
certain things and you change certain
values and these are the things that you
do in N number of times on an Excel and
this can all be done by simple automated
wave which is macros so what it does is
it is a set of tasks that you can
execute as many number of times as you
want
when you create a macro basically what
it does is it will record all your mouse
clicks and keystrokes
basically if for example you have your
monthly accounts report that is there
and it comes every day and you have to
put it in extract certain data and
remove certain columns that you do every
time that you open that sheet for
instance you remove that column I which
has the obsolete values of your of your
accounts or the sheets that you have and
you remove that column and you edit some
names you add such things every time
that you open that report and then you
format it in a proper way and send it to
your management so this can all be done
and a simple running script called
macros so what you do is you record
those
Mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically a
set of codes or a task that you can
execute and automate and it can be done
n number of times so it makes your life
easy now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your Excel it's a
simple tab that you need to add in the
ribbon section which I'll be showing you
across and this will enable the macros
on your Excel so you go to files
good options
and then you need to customize whatever
click customize ribbon and then there is
a developer tab which you see here it
should be activated so you just need to
select that
click on the tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macros now you you
have your data and you can run macros or
record a macro and run it all on your
Excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can add or remove your Macros from
here so this is two ways that you need
to that you can activate uh your Macros
so how you record a macro is the next
thing
so here I have a work orders sheet that
I receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do and you know this report has so
many things that are obsolete which you
do not need which has to be put across
to your management or your for your use
so how you record or start a macro you
go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro as soon as you click
on this record macro button it will
start recording your keystrokes on the
mouse mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that I have and we'll
try to run a macros on this and see what
it does
so here I have and
this actually works this way uh I need
to go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro so when I click record
macro it starts recording my mouse
clicks and keystrokes so in this sheet I
have to you know remove some columns and
the columns that are Obsolete and the
data that looks weird here should be
removed and all what I need is the work
order number the district and the
tactician name and the kind of service
that we provide and the requested
workday
the cost
and the payment so this is what I want
and I do it every day when I receive the
sheet and I have to make these changes
and send it across to the accounts team
so what I do is I simply automate this
by running a macro
so I go to
let's see how it records the macro
if I click record macro I save it as
work order
accounts
and I'll add a little description like
work order
for
housekeep
costs
click ok
and
see what I do is basically I add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper and then I
do not want this column I delete it I do
not want the number of technicians that
are there I do not want all these and I
also want deliver out the account and
what kind of payment this is very
crucial for the accounts team I do not
want any of these obsolete data
so I just delete this
okay
and then I just want to have some
cosmetic changes done so
and make sure this doesn't have any
border
and that's it this is the task that I
prefer
every day I still don't need it
and I go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now I have the macro
save and when I have it I have you know
automated these all these steps in one
simple click and how I execute it in
another sheet so I will show it across
to you
the next thing so here I have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and sent it across so I simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab and go to the macro and I
have this macro C which we ran the just
now and I simply with a single click I
will be able to do these daily tasks and
execute in a Flash so I just click run
and it does the rest for me I have my
report ready and is in a proper format
that is required and it can be sent
across so here as we see it is done in a
single click by running a simple macro
continuing our uh to work on macro we
can simply do this by a single click of
a button by adding a button so what you
have to do is go to the developer tab
and in the control section you will see
the insert option
when you click on the insert drop down
you will see a form controls and you can
say select a button and here I select a
button and the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro and when I just
assign that macro to this button I can
edit the text by
making it as
work order accounts just to make it
simple okay
and now if you see if I just click this
button it will run the macro
and format RC
So This Is How We Run The macros in a
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros or you can record
and you can edit your macro so when I
click view macros it will show you what
are the macros that I have and that I
can run and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab if you just click on record macro it
will do the same functions that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have to use a
simple application in Excel which is the
VBA Visual Basic application to edit
your macro you go to the developer tab
and then click on Visual Basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on and you
can edit the
macro here so as we see if you go back
to the Excel we see that uh obviously we
have been working on this heat and it
has the column still K and the actual
sheet is this so if I go to the Visual
Basic editor
and I'll make sure they know I remove
the columns that are existing from the
column m
and I just delete that and I click run
I go back to my sheet and you see these
changes are not there
okay
this is your old macro and this is our
new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority of my orders so
these are the things that we can edit
with the VBA what is VBA Visual Basic
application it is basically a Visual
Basic application language that is used
for macros in Excel
so what it basically does Visual Basic
core application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate tasks by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily tasks by running a
simple macro now to help us you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our abilities to
ease our work and automate a task we use
VBA so
why we be there are many advantages of
using VBA and why we prefer VBA in
macros for excel so basically it is a
very simple language it saves time in
performing tedious tasks you have number
of tasks that you do every day as we
have seen in the previous section how we
you can simplify your daily task by just
running a simple macro and this VBA
helps us in performing those tasks in a
very simple manner another thing is it
supports english-like statements there
are multiple statements that you can use
and which are very basic English
language statements and this can help us
or it is very easy to program our code
or edit these commands you can select a
range you can it is like a if an else
statement and things like that we'll
look into those in details in the next
sections now one more thing is it
improves the functionality of excel by
allowing you to make Excel behave the
way you want there are multiple
functions that you perform in Excel like
selecting a number of rows or columns or
selecting a set of cells in particular
you do it in a daily basis so these
things can easily be performed and
easily be edited and executed by using
VBA we will look into those in detail
now what is the BBA editor interface
this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have look in
detail where where you can edit your
commands or your codes for your Excel
now how this is achieved we will see it
here
now these are the this is basically the
VBA editor interface where you can see
the uh this is the toolbar section where
it shows all the options wherein undo or
save or file they will see those details
in the next section this is basically
the toolbar section of the VBA editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important menu
bar option and when you can insert
different modules and buttons and all
we'll look into those in details run is
one more important thing all these
things fall under menu bar the next
thing is the VBA code window VBA code
window as it says is the code window
where your actual code resides wherein
you can go into it and edit the code or
write the codes and select the different
range of functions that you can perform
and this is basically the bdb VBA code
window where you edit your or write your
codes
the next thing is the project Explorer
project Explorer is simply like a
Windows Explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your VBA
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the the Excel sheets or
the worksheets that you're working on or
the modules that you have saved and so
on basically it is an Explorer for your
PBA like a Windows Explorer which is for
the file explorer the next thing is the
properties window properties Windows
shows you the properties of the
worksheet that you're working on for
instance here we are working on the
sheet 2 and it shows the properties what
are the kind of uh
the worksheet that we have the page
break the right to left whether it is
enabled or not the name of the sheet and
so on whether it's visible and things
like that the next thing is the
immediate window and the watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window where then you can run and
execute simple lines of course
individual Excel code that you can run
it will allow you to test individual
lines
which is very useful and handy when you
are writing and debugging course uh the
output if the lines that you execute can
be seen here in the immediate window
whereas watch Window watch window is
similar to it but it displays the value
of the watch expression in its currently
current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the VBA code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the you the advantages of
having a watch window in your VBA
interface
so these are the things that we learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
Visual Basic for application for macros
and I'm going to show you how to you
know run some codes and run some macros
and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the VBA for macros so there are
two ways to open the Visual Basic
application and the first thing is you
can run alt f11 click on the sheet and
then just press and it will open the
Visual Basic for application window or
alternatively you can just go and click
on the Visual Basic I need to open the
sheet video I mean the code window
filling and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project Explorer
and this is the immediate window I will
you can run some testing course
immediately it will show you the uh code
so here we see the project Explorer
window where we see the modules and all
for our Visual Basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see how
the code develops okay so I just go here
and click record macro
and I save it as a format
and
columns
this QuickBook and I just save it click
OK and it has started recording so now
what I'll do is as make it simple and I
just delete some columns here
okay
I do not need this I delete this is
there a wait I want this I want the
amount of payment parts cost labor hours
I do not want this number of technicians
forget it
okay
and I go for the left and see what all
do I need I need I don't need this
I delete all these and
I just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then I want to change the format I
mean the hot
so I select this
[Music]
and I change it to timestrone
okay
yeah I'm going to go back to my
developer tab click stop recording it is
saved
okay
now go back to my code
and see the
macro here so we see the macro here and
we can see uh in detail what it looks
like so we see the code what it's doing
and what the macro run has generated the
code back so we see we have basically
the name of the macro is format columns
and what it is doing we are just
selecting The Columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee selected is the E
column that we have selected and then
again so on and the next thing is the
font selection that is mentioned we are
changing it to Times New Roman size is
11 so it is basically
a basic VBA code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with m sub so this
is the code or a format of the VBA code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
VB and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation I have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and I'll try to explain some
basic
functions and the commands and the codes
that we use to accomplish the tasks that
we with PBA
so as we see this is the blank sheet and
I have selected a new module for it
so here I start the code and as you see
is it starts with sub and I am
specifying the uh module name as a
number so I'll just try to make it quite
simple and
you know so we as as soon as we enter
the sub it sends with the ends up and so
this is the start of the code and this
is the end of the code and whatever is
there should be here and this is the
name of the code of the macro now uh
I'll explain it further about the game
statement why is it used and what is it
used for so dim is basically a keyword
which is the a short form of Dimension
and it is used to declare a variables in
the VBA so here I am trying to specify
uh
a variable called X and how I'm going to
do it I will as it have it as a number
or an integer or anything so here in
this example I'll put it as an integer
or a number okay and as I put as it
populates the prompt so I select integer
and for example I select the number to
be
500. okay and here I'm trying to assign
a variable integer a cell a value of 500
with a limb keyword
so where exactly I want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay range I am selecting it should be
under course where I'm going to put the
value of x as and I close the bracket
and what should be the value
[Music]
value should be X
so now as I click runs up
or you can do it with the by running the
alt F5 key and it will run the
cool so you see here in the Excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell B5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do with the dimension
keyboard or dim keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain or example some more examples
and how we assign the string value as a
as a text or
something else okay
now I'm going to show you what dim can
be executing used as to set variables
then can be used as a
double when double is basically a longer
form of single variable it usually takes
more space but uses needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can set
double and I just uh don't specify it
and we can use state
it basically stores the date values okay
and then again string so what string
does if you use string it stores the
text it can contain numbers it will have
some text as calculations or anything
can be performed so these are the basic
thing that I will cover and
you can also use different uh values for
it so I will discuss this in the next
example
okay
thank you
so in the next example I'll try to start
or use a string value for it and
I put it as a string
[Music]
value
this is my name so as soon as I hit
enter it ends with the answer prompt and
now I can edit my code so I put it as
time book it has
something
okay now
I'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the cells so let's see
how it goes and I select country and in
country I select the Mac
okay now what is the value or the cell
that basically takes the or we will put
the name of the country as so I have to
specify a range and as soon as I hit it
goes and I have to specify the
the cell here so here I put it as G
and 4 okay
so I close it
and I put a value what value I am going
to assign it is a country
[Music]
try to run this code
see G4 the name populates as a country
here so this is a dim keyword being used
as a string in our VBA code
so
we can also use
VBA to you know pop up a message on an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be executed
using uh the
code here which I am going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
foreign
[Music]
keyword I'm going to use the
keyword as double
y double is used is basically uh it
gives a longer it can be used for a
longer form of single variable ticks it
usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now I'm going to pop up a message in the
which says value of a is so and so so
I'm going to give value of a as
two five zero okay and how I it pops up
a message okay so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value I mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and you you can enter
the text and you can edit so here I'm
going to uh write a code which you know
which gives a pop-up message a message
box saying that the value of a is sorry
so
the value of a a
I'm going to put it in and percent code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay now that's it and let's try to run
this and you will see a message for
popping message box popping up
okay so the value of a is the message
box pops up saying the value of a is
250. so
in the next example I am going to write
a code wherein you know you can give a
value or a string you can assign it to a
selected cell and this basically used
when you have some you know when you
have a task of you know giving a value
to a particular cell or you have to
assign a text or say something about a
report okay so this let's see how it
goes and we use the
I will say it has a
fun with some procedures
[Music]
this is the name
again name
so here I am giving to I am going to
give a user input and it will be as a
string okay you can give an event I mean
any string or any statement what my user
input will be I will Define it here
[Music]
report
let's make it simple
okay
and where I'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell that I
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
I have defined user input as this is a
report by VBA so this cell turns into
you this is a report for VBA
I run this and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and you know it makes life quite simple
when you use VBA for this as we have
seen before we have used message box now
I'm going to use the same message box
to display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes I'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your name
and I'm going to put it under course
that my name is
[Music]
and we'll try to run it
see here
so it pops up a message saying that my
name is it fun so this is a message box
that you can display and I can do
anything with this uh
this is a PBA okay
okay I run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an Excel sheet or try to run a
Workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or you know Define a
report or kind of
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
now I have another good example wherein
you know you can write a code to
tell Excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so here it is
I'll put it as sub
number
and it will again populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
the entered
value
is
and it should tell me
which or I specify which cell it is that
we are going to find the value of okay
so I give a range
of
I have to give it in codes
I'm going to
thank you
go to computer
and it should tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell A1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use Excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
I can change it to
a
as well and try to run it and it will
give me the number so this is simple way
of you know populating a message box
which will tell us the
value of a uh let me show you one more
simple example where in a message box
pops up or a welcome message that can be
power set when you open the Excel or
worksheet so
so let's
name it as Auto
open
[Music]
and then again message box I wanted to
populate and what does it say
I put it in quotes welcome
[Music]
our
oh
Workshop
[Music]
it's very simple you just run it and
see it pops up a message saying it
welcome to a workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or do simple
welcome message on Excel
next I'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
curve
so we name it as add value
now I specify the range I mean where I'm
going to specify a cell
where the value will be given to the
cell
now I'm going to give it as B5
okay so put it as curves close the
parenthesis
what is the value that I'm going to give
value equals
250. okay so now with this code I mean
I'm going to assign a value of 250 to
the cell B5 let's see
run it see
again I do it to E10
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now I can run the same thing and give a
range of cells I mean
let me make it very simple here
I give it as B1
through
B
as
four five zero so let's see what it does
see here I'm going I'm specifying the
range to be B1 through B5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay in the
and then I can give another set of range
here
like let me specify it
range to be
[Music]
c one
I have to give it a course
[Music]
C4
and I separate it with a comma and I can
specify another range so the next one
will be D1 to D4
and then I close the codes close the
parenthesis however the value that I
give is
let's say
two three zero
and I try to run it
so it gives the value of c 1 through C4
and D1 through D4 as 230 has been
specified in the
code
so this is one of one more example
wherein you can assign values to the
uh so range of cells or cells and with
the BBA
one more thing I can you know assign a
value to a particular cell by specifying
these cells it's a very simple just
specify the cells like
oh six
[Music]
seven
I assign a value to it value equals
10. let's see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
Root 6
and columns happen
okay so this is one more example wherein
you can assign values to particular
cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario wherein you need to select
a
range of cells in the sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using VBA so I will show you
how
this is our
let's say select
range
and I am going to set a dim variable as
a example okay let's say it has example
and um what I'm doing is I'm specifying
a range because I need to select a range
of
cells okay now I'm going to set the
variable as
set example where I am going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected so let's say a one
to D
okay this will be the selection
and what I'm going to
set the value okay I am going to set a
value
example
I'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here I'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and I'm going to
assign a value with this function so
this makes it quite simple and this will
be used in a regular daily task wherein
you know there is there will be a
scenario where you have to select a set
of cells and give a give a value to it
so you can do it with the click of a
button of the VPN
now I can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so there is
I'll remove this
and instead of assigning a value I just
need an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then it's it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or cells with these
codes
now what if I want to do a selection of
the same rows and columns in the next
sheet and I can do this with the
set of another set of commands so I will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing and we specify the worksheets
okay
worksheets
I want it in sheet 2 okay so I just put
it as C2 and I activated it basically
activating it and now I am going to
specify the worksheet
2 and what is the range that I'm going
to select the same thing okay
the range will
be
A1
to D Phi
okay
what I'm going to do I am going to
select it
okay and see what happens here
okay
so here I am selecting the worksheet too
and I'm activating it and I'm going to
assign range and I'm going to select it
so I can just copy the same or select
the same set of cells in the next sheet
okay now when there will be as I said
there will be a you know by requirement
where you need to copy some cell
contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that it's uh
again a simple code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a copy
and paste I'm just making it simple by
giving something that we can understand
and relate and copy
[Music]
so what I'm going to do is I am going to
select this range and I'm going to copy
it and paste it somewhere here okay so
let me just remove this
and actually first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy the
cells okay so let's say it is again A1
it should be in codes
D5
of course
okay I am going to select it okay
then what I'm going to do is uh once you
select this the selection that you have
should what should be the function and I
am going to specify the selection and
the function should be copying it
okay so I just said that and where I'm
going to paste it so I have to now
specify the range where I have to paste
this selection and you can just mention
the
column here let's say G
uh
10.
okay
close it
I'm going to select it and then where
I'm going to paste it I can do it in
this sheet okay active sheet foreign
so we are selecting a range of cells
selection and that selection what we are
doing is we will copy it and now we are
going to specify the range where you are
going to
select it and then paste it
quite simple
let's
okay see
and
you can just change it to so it is
visible on this
G5
okay
so this makes uh quite easy
and you can run it
uh the next scenario will be like when
you need to get the count of the number
of cells like you have to have a
selection and you need to count the
number of cells so this can also be done
and it's quite easy
I am going to show it to you
let's say the summary
account
sales
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you are using it and
I'm going to set a variable let's say
I'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we will we
will specify the range of
the cells that we are going to that we
need to count basically so I'm going to
set a variable as array and then
what we are going to do is
basically
specifies by the range or your selection
where you will count the where you need
the count of the number of cells so even
85 oops
and now how you want the output you want
it you want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and
what should it give it will give you the
count of the variable that is the
variable is here is examples Okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this area
okay uh
let's see it says
okay here I think and list it so I just
specify the number here and let's see so
it gives you the number of
count and this is 20. okay
now let's see I want to
do six
so it gives you the selection so it's
quite simple it will be very useful in
our daily task and where you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
uh well I can further tweak this and to
determine the uh the count the number of
rows or columns so it's again very
simple I just need to do some changes
here I have to set the
column count
so if I want to
calculate the number of columns
[Music]
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message the number of columns
here
see it gives there are five columns okay
one two
one two three four five okay so it gives
us the number of columns here if I
change it to
should give me
four four
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
just change
three it says six rows are there
okay
foreign
so this way you can calculate the number
of count the number of cells number of
columns number of rows
with this
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the most widely used statement and
one whoever is in programming are very
much familiar with this function so what
it does is we specify a condition if a
condition is met then the output output
should be such and such we can specify
the condition and it will check whether
that condition is there and if it is
if it is achieved then you will have to
specify the output as well so this can
be achieved with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic uh English
language so you it's not very
complicated and I'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition and if
that condition is met then the result
you specify the condition and the result
port okay so this is one thing and then
you can specify the s or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
two then the result should be
this
so here you are going to specify two
conditions or multiple conditions where
you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or Maps
and you have to select the result you
can do this manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
I have it here
let's
specify as
okay
statement
okay now I have to specify the variables
now I have to have variables I have a
score and I have a result and the score
is an integer the number and the result
is a string path of a so I specify this
okay dim
score
as specified as integer okay
and then there's another variable that I
have to set the result
as string
okay
now what the score will be the score I
have to specify the range
score I am giving it as a range I mean
it's in my
cell A1
okay
I specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
should be alert
and then I'm specifying a condition here
if
score value the variable
is greater than or equal so as I said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
English language functions available
and then
the result result is another variable
that I have said result what it should
be it should be
in codes
okay so if this condition is met then
the result will be this okay
and now where I want to specify my
result I should give a range for that
so I give it in the next column or any
one
this is the basic uh example
value should be the result
okay let's see how it runs
see
press
change to 40.
it doesn't give me anything because I
have specified only one condition here
okay
2575 let's see how drums
see so they say it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables the score
and the result and then you are giving a
value for it and you are specifically
condition if the score is greater than
then the result should be passed
now in the next uh section uh we will
simply tweak this and use an if then
else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and c will specify
another condition and C so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's uh stick to the same
values
and now
I'm going to specify it and if the score
is greater than 60
then the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before and then
I'm going to specify another condition
here else
the result should be
okay
and now I have to put it as a and if
statement I have to specify the answer
and the result will be again in the
value I mean the range will be V1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is fail
okay this path let's see
40 and
run it again
it's okay so we are specifying two
variables again we are giving it a range
and we are specifying one condition if
this condition is met the result is
passed otherwise else it is failed so
another set of example
uh the next statement that we use uh or
we're going to discuss is the Loop
statement that is the for Loop statement
and why we use it there are there are
situations and uh tasks that you need to
execute and you need to do it several
number of times these are basically
executed sequentially it means one after
another so the first statement or the
function is executed and the next is
taken up so and then the next and so on
so these Loop statements allow us to
execute a statement or a group of
statements multiple number of times many
number of times and this happens only
when the first task or the first task is
done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we will discuss a
simple example of the for Loop statement
so let's see how it
works and I'm going to set up a
Loop statement okay again the I'm going
to make it as Loop one so here it is I
have to specify the
variable that is dim
and I'm going to specify X as an integer
okay I'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it is
okay for x equals to 1 2
94 okay let's see
and I'm going to specify the range
has
so what I'm going to do is basically I'm
going to fill the column A from 1 to 24
with some value from 1 to 24 that the
values of 1
through 24 okay
so I am setting up a range
and How It Ends is it gives me a value
now it executes this and goes to the
next one I'll explain you have it so we
are setting up a loop we are setting up
a an integer a variable X as integer and
we are setting the value of x to be 1 to
24 so here for 1 it executes the first
thing is it it takes X as 1. and it
fills in A1
and then the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to A2 and fills the value as
2 so just let's try to execute this and
you will see the
row column A filled with 1 through 24.
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as X
and the number of values is going to be
24. okay so this is one basic example of
a purloop statement
now let's do some more addition to this
uh
example by you know executing another
sector per Loop and giving the output
and we'll code the output to be the
color code advance in the column B so
how we do it it's a basic simple example
that I'm going to take and again what
I'm going to do is I will have this
values here and I am going to calculate
the
V column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see in
what I'm going to do is I'm only going
to change the B
and what action is going here we put a
value now we are going to select it and
with this selection
what I'm going to do is if you've select
it and it should color the interior with
what
foreign
X
and then I'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the
box to be colored and I'm going to put
it as a solid
you can fill the whole thing with the
solid
and then I just execute it see
it takes this
color B
and it's coded like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for Loop statements so there
are numerous examples and exercises that
we can perform tasks we can perform with
the BBA and this can be found in detail
in our next process Advanced courses
and with that we come to the end of this
live session on data analysis with Excel
I hope this session was interesting and
informative if you have any questions
then please feel free to put them in the
comment section thank you for watching
and keep learning